Good evening. In compliance with chapter
551 open meetings of the Texas
Government Code, I call to order a
regular voting meeting of the board of
trustees of the Austin Independent
School District for Thursday, September
25th, 2025 at 6:00 p.m. A quorum of the
board is physically present at Austin
ISD central office to conduct this
meeting. This meeting is being broadcast
on cable channel 22 through Spectrum
Estound Broadband and on channel 99
through AT&T Universe. Close captioning
in English is available on these
platforms for individuals who are deaf
or heart of hearing. Welcome and thank
you for joining us. We now move to
public testimony for items on our
consent agenda. Members of the public
public wishing to participate in the
public testimony portion of our meeting
called a dedicated Austin ISTD phone
line in advance of the meeting to sign
up to speak in person or to audio record
their remarks. Tonight we have three who
signed up to speak in person and we have
four who left a recorded message. We
will now move to in-person testimony. In
order to provide as many opportunities
for input as possible within a limited
time period at this meeting, each
speaker will be allotted one minute. No
substitutions or yielding of time to
others is permitted. Callers who signed
up to speak in person are welcome to
come to the microphone uh when their
name is called. As you come to the
microphone, please press the button to
turn it on. There is a device that will
light up as you move through your one
minute of aotted time. When the buzzer
sounds, please make a final thought in
one sentence. Again, we ask that whether
you come to give a complaint or praise
that you reference any staff member by
position or by abbreviated last name. We
ask that all audience members, whether
speaking or not, please show respect for
others at all times. Our in-person
speakers for tonight are Steve Swanson,
Maria Alice Ruiz, and Shannon Kho.
Am I on? Good evening, Steve Swanson.
Uh, thank you for the agenda item 10.4,
four board guard rails that states the
board will not exclude community voices
when making major district-wide
decisions. Our school planning
experiences reveal the urgent need for
authentic community-based planning as
provided for in the Texas education
code. The current harmful school
turnaround planning must stop and TA
must start fulfilling its statutory
responsibilities to provide AISD
training in authentic community-based
planning. To help AISD attorneys and
community members committed to the Texas
Lawyers Creed with the support of the
Supreme Court of Texas and the Texas Bar
Foundation have recently obtained the
TEA's General Council's commitment to
the creed. Tonight, the TA's general
counsel is publicly encouraged to honor
the creed by providing the TEA with an
informed understanding of its
responsibilities in providing AISD
training and community based planning in
of our schools to you to our teachers
and to our communities. I welcome your
questions and hope you review the
handout. Thank you.
Thank you. Our next speaker uh who
signed up to speak is uh Maria Alice
Ruiz.
Thank you.
>> Turn on which button? This one right
here.
>> Yeah, we hear you. I think
>> it's on already. Okay, great.
There it is. Good evening,
Superintendent Matias and esteemed board
of trustee members. Uh, thank you for
the opportunity to speak tonight. I want
to say thank you for my 40-year pen. I'm
starting my 451st year and uh I'm
excited that I've had that opportunity
to work for AISD title one schools. Um,
I serve as the dyslexia interventionist
at Sanchez Elementary School and I
obtained an additional certification to
continue with with services for our
children at Sanchez Elementary School. I
would like to address the AISD 2025
assessment results that's based on the
state's in my opinion flawed
accountability system.
Um, which brings me to the turnaround
plan which he spoke about inclusive of
our student population. As you review
our plan, our top t plan, I ask or I
urge you, each of you, to consider
significant causal factors that we've
been faced with. Oh my goodness. So, I
will provide you a list of those factors
and I want you to think about this
question. what is best for our students.
That we retain our certified teachers
and continue providing services to our
current science population, our student
population, and that we get the support
that you've outlined in some of these
plans um just like they will in the
future, but we should have had received
in the past because of our causal
factors. Uh in closing, I want to thank
you the opportunity for allowing us to
speak on behalf of our uh parents and
children, families, community that are
not able to be here because of
extenduating circumstances.
And I do I have three seconds left.
>> Three. Yes. Thank you. We appreciate you
being here.
>> I'll provide you this information.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. I appreciate it. Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
>> It's my 46th year, actually.
>> Thank you.
That's excellent. Thank you so much for
that, for being here and being here. Uh,
last is Shannon Kho.
Shannon with us. All right, we'll listen
to our recorded calls next. And if
Shannon comes before um we move on with
our meeting, we'll stop and listen to
Shannon as well. Um, so we will now play
the recorded messages for public
testimony. Please listen carefully. My
name is Leticia Anderson, former uh
trustee, calling to give public comment
on agenda item 14.2.
The district's own scorecard highlights
five constraints. Serving underserved
students, engaging caregivers,
addressing disparities for marginalized
groups, protecting early learning, and
ensuring access to social and emotional
supports. On paper, these commitments
sound powerful, but the picture they
paint today is one of failure. Families
are still left out of the
decision-making. Historically,
marginalized groups continue to face
inequities. Caregiver engagement is
minimal, and communities are silenced
instead of empowered. Early learning
protections is exist in writing, but not
in practice. Mental health supports are
promised, yet many campuses remain
underresourced. This gap between what
you say and what you do shows a lack of
accountability. You cannot celebrate
equity and inclusion on paper while
ignoring the live realities of students
and families. The community deserves to
see these words become action, not empty
statements. Thank you. My name is
Leticia Anderson coming on agenda item
7.1.
The 2025 star results reveal that many
students have not regained pre-COVID
performance levels, especially in math
and English. While there is some
progress in areas like 8th grade reading
and science, too many grade levels
continue to decline, the data shows a
clear pattern of unfinished learning. We
must also recognize the overuse of COVID
as a reason for failure. District
leaders continue to point to the
pandemic years instead of addressing the
structural gaps uh inequities and
ineffective strategies that remain.
Families and teachers have moved
forward, but the district has not. Our
students deserve solutions, not excuses.
Leadership must take accountability,
invest in proven interventions, and stop
hiding behind the pandemic as the
explanation for continued
underperformance. Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Jessica and I'm a parent
at San Elementary where many of our
parents, staff, and students are
disheartened about the AISD mandating a
trap that is following a harmful
timeline. Constraint five on the updated
s scorecard indicates that the goal was
moved to have zero campuses with F-
ratings by 2029. With scores being
withheld and new mandates being
required, our timeline for implementing
taps should be reconsidered. Given that
we have four years to meet the scorecard
goal, communities need time to process,
gather, discuss, and create solutions to
these surprise mandates. Plans need to
be made with our children in mind and
not the to the detriment of their
emotional health. And we need to be able
to do this while trusting that the
district is going to hear and consider
our thoughts. I understand that changes
must be made for the improvement our
schools. So please, let's make these
changes responsibly, respectfully, and
legally. We can start by giving our
communities the time and the support
they need. Thank you.
>> Good evening. My name is Helen Miller. I
want to raise a concern about the
interroal agreement between Austin
Independent School District and Austin
State Hospital. While this agreement is
important, it leaves out a critical
piece. Families in Austin Independent
School District who have a child
experienced a mental health crisis who
may need impatient care are not
guaranteed access to these services
through this agreement. That gap places
an unnecessary burden on parents who
already facing urgent and difficult
situations. We must ask why are are our
students and families not included when
mental health crisis are on the rise. I
also want to know if Austin uh
Independent School District still has an
agreement with Travis County and how
that agreement connects to providing
immediate and comprehensive mental
health support for our students. Our
families deserve clear answers and
access to real solutions, not barriers,
when they need help the most. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Um, has Shannon Kho come?
That's the other person who has signed
up to speak in person. All right. Thank
you. Um, that concludes our public
testimony. Trustees, are there any
questions or clarifications?
All right. Thank you very much. And
thank you to all of our speakers in
person and all of the people who called
in to share your concerns and um,
thoughts. As a reminder, please feel
free to share any general comments or
questions on items with the board by
email at trusteesaustinisd.org.
Um, next up is a president's report. I
want to take a moment to recognize that
we are in National Hispanic Heritage
Month, which began on Monday, September
15th, and runs through October 15th.
This is a time to honor the histories,
cultures, and incredible contributions
of Hispanic Americans to our nation.
Here in Austin ISD, this month holds a
special significance. Our district is a
vibrant tapestry woven with the threads
of many cultures, and our Hispanic
students, staff, and families are a huge
part of who we are and what we do. I
invite everyone to join us in
celebrating the rich heritage that makes
Austin ISD so strong. October is just
around the corner and Texas has
designated October um the month of
October as fentinil poisoning awareness
month to increase theware awareness of
the dangers of fentinil and potential
overdoses.
More than 150 people die every day from
overdoses related to synthetic opioids
and by educating ourselves we can
protect our students and work to prevent
these losses in our community. Thank you
for that. Um want to remind people too
in the spring Austin ISDPD uh involves
itself in a drug a prescription drug
takeback program. So we'll update you
about that in the spring. Uh our next
item is committee reports. We've posted
the written committee report as an
attachment to this item on our board
docs agenda. This includes a committee
report for the board policy committee.
And the next item is our superintendence
report.
>> All right. Thank you, President Boswell.
um board of trustees. Uh we'll be
pulling up here the superintendent
report. Uh the first thing I want to
acknowledge is that um there are a lot
of things occurring right now within
Austin ISD. Uh we often talk about them
as a team. We certainly talk about them
with our board and with our community,
but I think it's important to just maybe
kind of show visually just all the
things that we are working through in an
effort to have stronger neighborhood
schools.
Certainly the work around the TA order
uh is still ongoing. The work around
program alignment ensuring that our
boundaries are aligned to support
student and keep communities together as
they move through our system. The
challenges that we have as we navigate
the evershifting accountability system
in the state of Texas all while trying
to ensure that we have resources to
ensure we have high quality education
occurring in our campuses. Um, and so
it's important that we talk about this.
I'm going to provide a couple updates
where we are in these efforts, but it's
important just to tell our community and
our staff and our board uh that we are
committed to the work. Uh, it is all
occurring uh at the same time and we
appreciate everybody's grace and
patience as we work through it.
So, the one thing I I'd like to talk
about next is the academic framework uh
effort that is going to be uh underway.
I think it's important that we define
what an academic framework is. Uh it's
an academic framework creates the
structures for quality and alignment of
the district's educational plan,
ensuring that high quality learning
experiences are available to all
students. You know, a moment ago, you
heard me talk about neighborhood uh and
the strength of our neighborhood
schools, and we certainly recognize that
we have strong neighborhood schools, but
we do not necessarily have that strength
everywhere in our district. and we all
need to align to ensure that that occurs
and every student has that access and
support. And so as we move the work uh
forward, there are a couple things that
I want to point our community to and our
board. Uh and that's work around some of
the liberals that you'll see in November
as we move towards uh some votes in late
November and and certainly as we move
into the spring semester. First is the
academic foundation. Uh we'll be
identifying and building out our guiding
principles, guiding vision, our baseline
academic program. Uh Dr. Maxwell will be
um supporting and leading much of that
work alongside the team, myself and
others. Uh we recognize this is a this
overall effort is many many months. Uh
and certainly we have a lot of great
documents that we can rely on, but
ultimately speaking there are some
milestones that we need to be aligned on
and ensure are communicated out before
we take uh some of these next steps over
the next couple months. The academic
framework development process is
deliverable that will also be included
uh in upcoming meetings. It'll lay out
all the different milestones, the levels
of um effort when we're going to engage
with community. One of the things that
we are committed to do uh doing is
making sure that uh we engage with
community. Uh we um listen to those who
may not have a voice in certain spaces
to ensure it's a groundup effort. Uh
that does take time. Uh and we're
committed to doing the work.
Uh I also like to provide an update
regarding uh accountability and the work
that we're doing to be responsive uh to
our turnaround plans. Uh the work uh has
been uh significant over the last many
weeks. Uh as you can see here the
different um campuses that have been uh
identified by the state as needing to
complete turnaround plans. the 3UA and
UA stands for unacceptable and then 2UA
uh are the two two unacceptable counts.
Uh these are the schools that we have
been working uh with to develop uh these
turnaround plans. The next slide
includes a timeline of where we are in
the overall process. Uh much of this
work uh had been building up um as we
closed out uh last school year and into
the summer. But the def the definition
around the timeline and submission of of
deliverables to TA became codified once
we received notication from the agency.
So you can see here on this timeline uh
the different milestones. The one thing
that I would like to bring to our
trustees and to our community's
attention is that there has been a a
slight change uh in when the um
submission of the taps is required. Um
when we first were notified from the by
the agency it was on November 14th. We
just found out about a day ago that it
had um it's now been moved to the 21st.
Um we recognize that we have a board
meeting on the 20th and so acknowledging
that this uh time does allow for
additional engagement also allows for
sequencing with the board uh we are
looking to um submit on the 21st which
aligns up well with the board meeting on
the 20th kind of ensuring that
everything comes together uh as a
thoughtful plan opposed to broken up um
or out of sequence.
Next slide. Uh we uh are going to
continue to have um feedback
opportunities. Uh these have been going
on over the last couple weeks. Uh CAC
meetings, principal coffees, uh
different feedback forms have all been
um uh made available and we'll continue
to do so. On the next slide, we just
want to encourage our families and
community to get engaged. Uh there's a
lot uh going on in Austin ISD and we are
wanting to bring families into the
process. Uh we certainly recognize that
the timeline is not uh a timeline that
we would um like to have. We would
prefer more time but the constraints
given to us by the state require um that
we kind of maintain this current effort.
Uh always uh it's important for us to
always communicate you know engaging
with your campus, engaging with your
teachers. Uh we also um are making every
effort to make sure that our families
understand where their students are in
their academic journey. Uh one new
change that I think hopefully trustee
Singh appreciates, I'm just kidding,
teasing you, uh is we're really trying
to make it easy for families to access
the report cards. Uh we've heard over
the last two and a half years, two years
that accessing the portal, which is a
challenge for me and I have two
daughters in the system, uh is is
challenging. It's difficult. So, one new
change that I I hope our families have
already seen in a progress report that
came through not too long ago uh was
just simple access from your phone. So,
you can receive it. Click on a button
and it actually pops up. Uh it is very
easy, doesn't require portal access. Uh
I want to thank um the team certainly
Alli Gaduchi and Oscar Rodriguez for
doing that. Uh it's really the it gives
us the ability to ensure that our
families have easier access to
information around their students
progress uh but also acknowledges that
everybody accesses information
differently and it's been a challenge
for us in the past and this is I think a
good balance given the kind of cost uh
constraints that we have as an
organization. So just wanted to bring
that to everybody's attention. Uh really
excited about the work that we're able
to accomplish as we move forward. also
want to provide an update where we uh
regarding the work um around school
consolidations, boundary changes, feeder
pattern alignment and program changes.
Uh as I've said before, this is all an
effort to evolve the organization to get
to a place where we have a balanced
budget multi-year but are protecting the
quality of education in Austin ISD. And
most importantly, uh we're doing it in
alignment with our values. So there will
be opportunities to reduce cost. Uh
we're going to be working to um ensure
that we have a clear understanding of
what the programs will be at and what
our families can expect at every
elementary school, middle school, and
high school. Uh what services and what
supports will be there. Uh and also do
what we can to ensure that families as
they move through our system are not
broken up. Uh and that will um really
kind of kind of lean into who we are as
an organization. We know that the
breaking up of communities is something
that uh has been a challenge for us as
an organization with the germandering
that we've had with boundaries for
decades. And so we do view this as an
opportunity to correct a lot of things
that have occurred over the last 140
years. Um and again what's most
important here is we've got to do this
while uh ensuring alignment with our
values uh and not sacrificing any of
those along the way. So, if we don't
take this on, uh there are lots of
things that I get asked about about what
could happen and uh some of these are
scary and and I certainly um acknowledge
that. But for us as an organization,
ensuring financial solveny and our
ability to make payroll and having cash
on hand is critically important. uh
every budget process we've gone through
as Katrina as a CFO we've we've really
been intentional about showing how uh
the cash that we have the income of
revenue from our t tax revenue and then
the cash outlays by way of recapture or
other expenditures really is tenuous and
anytime that we eat into our uh fund
balance it introduces risk. Uh certainly
also want to recognize that if we don't
take action now um as costs for
education continue to rise um it'll make
future decisions uh even more
disruptive. We also don't want to shy
away from the fact that if we don't do
this uh we will lose the ability to do
it in a way that meets um our values and
how we would want to do it. Uh and if we
don't do it then someone else most
notably the state could do it. Uh and so
there are lots of elements to this. Um
we often talk about the timeline given
where we are in the process and and
wanting to get to a vote in November.
One of the things I say often is that we
our families need time to plan and that
time is critically important in the
spring semester as we look at changes in
the 2627 school year. uh and certainly
the disruption to the enrollment system,
the opportunity for students to go
through course selection, all of that
starts in November. So, in an effort to
to maintain continuity in our family's
experience and to support transitions,
uh we strongly feel that this time and
this timeline is adequate.
um uh but certainly uh recognize that it
does also feel um very constrained um
and there is a lot of of pressure uh in
the at the moment.
So uh one quick if you go to the next
slide, one thing that I think is often
just um useful to kind of bring back is
is just where we are as an organization.
Um the uh you know as a you know
certainly we're taking all the
reductions we can in budget but it's
important to note what we're protecting.
You know over the last year we as an
organization in collaboration with the
board have said we are going to protect
planning time. We are going to protect
um and and ensure that uh our focus on
librarians supportive librarians is
maintained. We are going to also ensure
that um we compensate staff to the best
of our abilities. These things we have
committed to uh but in exchange for that
we have to make difficult decisions and
this graphic here is a little dated but
I think it's worth kind of bringing back
showing if we don't continue to make
decisions uh the the disruption um will
only increase. As we move to the next
slide just wanted to uh kind of
reinforce where we are in the uh road
map. Uh we introduced this in the
spring. Uh we are still continuing to
hit our milestones uh as committed. Uh
the team has been working uh very hard
uh lots of meetings, lots of engagement
and we are in the process of building
out transition frameworks uh working to
make sure that we can support staff
through any transition, making sure that
we have homes uh in Austin ISD for those
who who choose to stay with us in the
event that there is a transition.
There's a lot of thoughtful work
occurring um but it is very very
difficult. As we move to the next slide,
just a reminder um of where we are in
the process. Uh we had kind of the data
um component of it that really kind of
came to conclusion in the in the late
summer. We've now kind of brought gone
into the contextual analysis component
where we're really thinking through kind
of long-term system improvement. What we
understand about the lived experiences
of those in the community. um making
adjustments, making refinements, and we
are moving towards um a plan uh that
will not be final. It will not be a
recommendation at this point, but it
will be something that we share with our
community on October 3rd when we upload
uh onto boards.
The next slide uh includes um just a
ongoing uh comm community uh community
engagement opportunities. Uh we have
some open houses coming on October 14th,
16th, 27th, and 1st. uh it'll be
combination of virtual and in person.
The other thing I also want to call out
is the phase 2 survey. Um the deadline
has been extended. It's been out there
for a little bit, but it has been
extended now to Monday the 29th. Uh and
again, you know, all of this um is very
helpful. Uh it helps us understand, you
know, how we can improve all of the work
um and hopefully move us in a direction
uh to get to that stable state. And as I
close out, I just want to just reinforce
that there are hard things that we're
having to navigate. Um, a lot of it is
based on things that have occurred in
the past. Um, and uh, but I do believe
that we can do these difficult things
uh, as long as we do them together. And
so with that, I'll hand it back to you
uh, President Boswell to continue on
with the meeting.
>> Great. Thank you. I appreciate that
report.
And um trustees, do we have an we have
an opportunity to ask questions? A
council correct on the superintendent's
update.
>> Christine,
>> we have an opportunity to ask questions
about the superintendent's update.
Correct.
>> You can ask questions. Yeah. Uh you just
can't get into deliberation.
>> Yeah. Perfect. Okay. So, do we have any
clarification questions? Yes.
Uh Christina uh you said no deliberation
but I have a request. Can I make a
request or ask a question or ask?
>> You can ask like a clarifying question.
Yes.
>> Okay. You mentioned that on the open
houses they would have um virtual
options for families but the uh the
turnaround programs I noticed they don't
have them. Are they going to have uh
virtual opportunities for people to
engage?
You wanna Chris the Ali I don't want to
misspeak.
So I believe the plan Good evening
everyone. All Alej senior executive
director of communications and
engagement. So the plan is for three of
them to be virtual. Um, we'll do one
that's focused on north, roughly north
of the river, one that's focused on
south, and then we'll have two more that
are kind of we're calling them the mega
meetings where we're going to start
talking about north for the first
>> the turnaround,
>> but she asked if they were going to be
ver the consolidation with virtual or in
person, right?
>> Not the consolidation, the taps.
>> So, the tap meetings have just
concluded.
>> Yes, I know. Um, I think I'll have to
have a conversation uh with the
superintendent. I know that everybody
worked at their capacity, but I know
that we still have um a need for some
continued communication around those uh
turnaround plans. Uh but as far as the
consolidation, appreciate it. Thank you.
>> And moving forward for the taps there
the there will be opportunities at the
campus advisory council meeting,
principal coffees, um staff meetings and
those things moving forth. So it's not
just this one and done opportunity. I
just but this week I had two schools at
the same time
>> which didn't matter because I was
teaching but I you know I could have
logged in and you know engaged in some
sort of way with each one of those but
there was no way I could get from Pan
Springs to Oak Springs to do anything
>> right. It was um the time constraint
like you said of having to double up
meetings. We actually we literally had
to have two every evening in order to
get them all done this week. Um but
again we we do recognize the importance
of having inerson opportunities. Um and
so we'll do those again through coffees.
Most of our principles do offer a hybrid
model for their copies so that you can
participate virtually and then they have
a group in person as well.
>> Okay.
>> Um and yeah so we are being responsive
to you know to the needs of the
community while trying to work within
our capacity of the team.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any additional clarifying
questions? Trusty Sing.
>> Thank you. Um I really appreciate um all
the work that you all are doing. So just
thank you. It's a heavy lift. Um if you
don't mind bringing up that slide that
had um the baseline academic program and
the other things that were listed in the
framework.
Oh, and also thank you for the report
cards. And you waited until after both
my kids graduated. So cool.
>> Thank you. I know. I'm just teasing. I'm
teasing.
Um, okay. So, could you talk Thank you
so much for doing this and I know this
is a huge push to get this in while
we're doing consolidations and TAP and
everything else. Um, could you talk a
little bit more about what we might
expect with the baseline academic
program in particular as part of the
November deliverables?
>> Yeah. So, so I'll start and then tr Dr.
Max.
>> Yeah. And a real brief. It doesn't have
to be like super deep, but
>> do you want to
>> Yeah. So, um, so two things, right? So,
it it is it is something that we've been
wanting to do and have been committed to
doing for for quite a while. The
challenge that we've had is that we
recognize that community um involvement
is necessary to get to where we want to
be as as far as a built out very
thoughtful, deliberate um framework,
strategic plan uh for AISD. Um over the
last year because of what we've been
going through, it's been difficult to
introduce it. Uh but we certainly
recognize that there is a need um to get
certain things established before we go
too far along to ensure alignment with
the the votes that will be coming in
over the next month and a half. So what
you're going to see, so the academic uh
um there's two things. Academic
framework development process. Uh again,
it's about an 18-month process, perhaps
a little bit shorter. Uh there are three
phases within it. Um they're still in
draft form. Uh we're going to be working
with Dr. Maxwell and the team to lay out
each of those milestones so that you
know our trustees in our community will
see when we're going to go to community.
You'll see when we're going to go to um
you know campuses uh and um how that's
ultimately going to find its way into
the work, what revisions to policy need
to occur, etc. the um academic
foundation. And this is something that
we actually struggle to find a word for
because there are lots that can be
interpretation can be very very
different for different people. And so
what we're wanting to to do is what um
what is our um expectation when it comes
to the core components of AISD
um you know not only from uh a um kind
of attitude or like things that we want
our students to learn and feel and grow
into as they move through the system but
also uh what do we what our expectation
around literacy uh you know
fundamentally what do we believe in have
it be very very clear and then
communicate how that finds its way into
the work. Um, and so one of the things
that we're working through right now and
hasn't been finalized is can you
organize it to the three kind of largest
components of the scorecard and then
kind of build out. Um we're working to
kind of establish that, but it will be a
document um that establishes kind of
like the either the base minimum uh
programs uh the clear expectations uh
and then where appropriate um kind of uh
curriculum or programmatic alignment. I
don't know. Anything else you want to
add to it?
>> Pretty good.
>> Yeah. And and I want to be really clear,
you know, it is really meant to be a
foundational document. Um, you know, I I
think that there's lots of things that
we have done together over the last two
years, um, or even before that that I
think will ensure that we're in a really
good we have a good starting spot,
starting point, whether it's the work we
did around the LRP, the work we did
around the equity assessment, the things
that y'all learned as y'all hired a
superintendent, like all of those things
uh, kind of have are aligned. We just
need to bring them all together with
input and kind of create this like
starting point to ensure alignment and
then we'll build it all the way out. And
my my my hope is that as we get through
these uh the work in November and
December and we enter into spring, we'll
be hopefully through the um special
education uh order. um the work um will
become clear around our next steps for
the turnaround plans and we will have um
be working through transition for any
changes tied to boundaries and
consolidations that'll really create the
space I think to kind of grow uh and
really move this organization and I
think where we all want it to go. So
>> appreciate that a lot. I know that's a
heavy lift. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any additional clarifying
questions? I have just one on slide
number 15 uh where we have the the
trajectory of unassigned fund balance
and I know um we approved a budget at um
15% fund balance with a change in policy
and uh some projections about where
those savings were going to come from
and I'm just wondering um what the plan
is for continuing to update us on the
progress of that work. Yeah. So, um in
the June, I guess June 26 board meeting,
we approved, uh the um the budget and we
talked about coming back. Uh we are
working through uh to make sure we have
either the budget updates or provide
updates on any uh reductions in cost. Uh
there's other something else that we
also want to communicate is where we
actually ended up. You know, on June 26,
we actually had not closed out June
financials. So, there are a couple
different um data points that we want to
update the board with. Katrina and I I
think have identified when it's going to
occur. Um it hasn't been codified, but I
would say probably um certainly I think
before the November vote there'll be an
update where we can share where we are
um and any future cuts that maybe were
not taken or were taken or expect to be
taken. And then we also have a budget
amendment I think coming back um January
>> October
>> October. And so that'll be part of that
conversation as well.
>> Thank you. And I'd love to make time for
maybe a conversation with that budget
amendment just to be sure we understand
since we are really we have some targets
we're working to hit. That would be
really helpful.
>> Um thank you.
>> And I had a question. Um you know with
with the the TEA um punishment plans are
given to campuses. Um they're very very
narrow what the district can do. um what
op what choices can we give families?
How how can we meaningfully include them
and you know not tell them what's going
to happen? There has to be you know even
though the options are very very limited
um you know h how are we listening to
what families need and how can we
include them in having some choice and
some say um of what's happening with
their child next year.
Yeah. No, I appreciate that, Trusty
Willy Chu. And that's um you're right.
You know, that the system is designed to
have fewer and fewer options the further
you progress down um uh the um
accountability
um or the string of of unacceptable
accountability ratings. And so for us uh
as an organization, we've had these
conversations. we have not been able to
to support or kind of reinforce some of
the options that would be available if a
school was at two years versus three.
And one of the things that's been
somewhat confusing is that we're
actually tackling two-year and
three-year at the same time. Uh and so
as we move forward, um what we're
intending to do is to provide um a
framework for uh those that we know will
be likely supported by the agency. Uh
also acknowledging that what we hear
from community will help inform kind of
out of the few options we have which one
likely will be the the path forward
while we're also taking on
consolidations boundary changes and
program movement. And so um these
meetings that we've had with our
principles have been very helpful. Uh
they're helping inform our um draft
turnaround plans. Um they're being
they're going to begin to be drafted
this week into next week and the
following week. Um and so I I do
acknowledge that for the threeyear um
we're limited um or more limited than if
than two-year. Uh but I do want our
trustees and our community to know that
as we think about different scenarios,
we do test those and get feedback
verbally um from from folks in the
agency to see if we're on the right
track. Um so we're doing where we can.
Uh we just not we just don't have a
great amount of options. And so like I'm
asking like beyond the TA required
punishments um of like what
families can choose like how close will
a campus be that if if they have to move
or um where their teachers will be
moved, how they can stay together as a
cohort. Um so those things outside of
TEA. Yeah.
>> Um I think families like I know um like
want to we want to be included. We want
to have as much say as possible. So I
guess my question is how um how can that
happen?
>> Yeah, that's the that's really the
transition planning u process. And so
once we have uh and I think in most
cases we're getting closer and closer to
having a defined strategy. Uh the work
is going to be um with our principles,
our executive directors and assistant
superintendents to actually lay out the
transition plans. Um those will be
project manag project managed within
central office so that you know it's
really clear what's the transportation
plan what's the staffing plan uh program
movement that may need to occur within a
campus um if it's going through a tap or
otherwise uh so all of that will be
detailed out um as we present and get
feedback you know we want to hear that
from our families um so that'll be part
of the process some of it will be done
now I would say that the details and
some of the um minor elements that are
going to have to come out as part of the
process. What we're hoping to accomplish
are the larger elements um up into the
vote and then as we get past the vote,
we work out all the details and then
into transition in the spring. Um we're
doing a lot. We're getting I think
everything aligned. Um, but there are
just some things that we're not going to
be able to to know until we get the
principles and the community all
together to build out our plans which
are different than what we submit to
TEA. Uh, in every case what we submit,
what we have, what we work off is much
more detailed, uh, I would say more
thoughtful of community input um, but
not necessarily what's required.
Good. Okay. Any additional
clarification? Okay. Thank you. Um and
thank you for the report. Um next we're
moving into an agenda preview for an
October 9th voting item. That's a voting
item that's going to happen at our
October 9th information session. We're
adding a voting item um because we have
a deadline to meet by October 14th. Um,
the board would be be voting on a
resolution to nominate candidates to
serve on the Travis Central Appraisal
District Board of Directors for a 4-year
term beginning on January 1st, 2026.
And our nomination by resolution is due
to TCAD by October 14th. We are
accepting applications through September
30th, 2025. And um I believe as last
time the officers will meet and together
and come up with a recommendation um for
the board and there's a new system for
doing that um where points and
opportunities to nominate are allocated
based on um a system of points based on
the tax base of each um group. Are there
any questions on this item?
>> All right. Thank you. who I really uh
hope that people in our community will
serve. And to clarify, um Josh isn't
here. Maybe our attorneys can help. Oh,
yes. Um people who are employees of the
district are not allowed to apply under
Texas law. Is that correct?
>> That is correct.
>> Okay. So, I want to be sure we had some
very qualified staff members apply last
time and we had to um reject those
applications. We couldn't consider them
and I don't want anyone to be spending
their time applying for something that
we have to say no to outright. So, um,
thank you for anyone who's interested
who works for the district. Um, but I I
we don't want you wasting your time. So,
thank you. I appreciate that. Any
questions about that?
All right. Thank you. We're going to
move on to uh scorecard student
achievement and scorecard goals. Uh, Mr.
Surre, can you please introduce this
item?
>> Yes, President Boswell. Um, joining me I
have Joshua Jun, executive director of
governance accountability and board
services and Dylan Fenan, director of
campus and district accountability to
present on the Austin ISD 2025 state
assessment results.
>> All right. Good evening, President
Boswell, Superintendent Sugura, board of
trustees. This evening we will be
presenting on the star results from the
24 uh 25 school year. uh we will not be
covering the accountability information
as that will be a part of the taper
annual report presented in February.
On this slide you'll see our spring 2025
assessment calendar. Um you'll notice
that we first test uh reading language
arts and then science and social studies
um and then math both for elementary and
uh the middle and high school levels.
for star 3 through eight. Uh reading,
language arts, and math are administered
for all the grades from grades three
through eight. Uh while science is
administered for students in grades five
and eight only and social studies is
administered for 8th grade only. Um and
STAR Spanish is available for students
in grades uh 3 through 5.
This slide um shows us the recent STAR
administration history. Um, in the 2019
2020 school year, STAR was not
administered because of the CO9
pandemic. In the following two school
years, we saw a drop in participation
because of the public health situation.
And ahead of the 2022 23 school year,
the STAR went uh underwent a major
redesign. Uh, some notable changes in
the administration of STAR 2.0 included
all students being expected to test
online um and receive accommodations uh
in the online testing platform. Uh there
were new question types including new
non-multiple choice questions. Um
assessments that included
crosscurricular passages that aligns to
Texas uh essential uh knowledge and
skills for other subject areas and
evidence-based uh writing in RLA
assessments which was a shift from essay
responses for a standalone prompt to uh
writing a response based on a reading
passage scored on a new uh fivepoint
rubric.
Good evening. Now, we're going to jump
into looking at the actual results.
We're going to start by looking at 2025
STAR 3 through 8 results. Um, and we're
going to start looking at reading star 3
through 8. In this graph, we're looking
at reading results for grades 3 through
8 combined. Um, when we compare 24 to
25, we see an increase in meets and
above and a decrease in the percentage
of students that did not meet.
When we look at results for middle
school English one EOC um taken in
eighth grade, we see a significant
increase in mastery. When we compare 24
to 25,
here we're looking at STAR reading
results in grades 3 through 8 um broken
up by grade level. Um we see a steady
increase in did not meet in fifth grade
reading results over time. A steady
increase in meets and above and sixth
grade reading results over time. And
from 24 to 25 um there was an increase
in the percentage of students that meets
and above in eighth grade.
Now we're going to shift and take a look
at math. Once again we're looking at
math um 3 through 8 results combined
longitudinally over time. In this graph,
um, we see stabilization in STAR 38 math
results after significant decrease in
2024 and we see a slight increase in
mastery in 25.
When we jump into middle school algebra
1 results, um, we see that they've been
relatively consistent over time and we
still haven't rebounded to our, um,
postcoid performance levels.
Here we're taking a look at math results
broken up by grade level. Um between 24
and 25 we see an increase in performance
at meets and above in grades three and
eight with greater growth in grade
eight. Um we have seen a steady decline
in math performance in grades three,
five and seven over time and grade six
shows no clear trend.
When we look at science five and eight
results um we saw an increase in overall
performance this past year after three
years of continuous
when we look at um science 5 and 8
separately um fifth grade performance
seems to have stabilized and we saw a
slight increase in performance overall
while in eighth grade we saw um a more
significant increase in performance at
all performance levels.
When we look at social studies star 8,
um we see a slight increase in masters.
Um no significant change in performance
since 2022 though overall.
Now we'll take a shift and start looking
at star EOC results.
Um now we're looking at star ELA EOCC
results. Between 24 and 25, we saw no
significant change in English one
results and we've seen a steady decrease
in English 2 results since 2022.
When we look at EOCC algebra 1 results,
um in 2025, we have seen slight
improvements in students performing at
meets and above, but at the same time,
we're seeing slightly higher rates of
students that did not meet.
When we take a look at our STAR EOCC
biology results, um we've seen slight
improvements in students performing at
meets and above, but once again, we see
slightly higher rates of students at did
not meets
in STAR EOCC history results. Um while
these have fluctuated over time, we do
not see any large shifts in overall
performance levels. And once again, um
the percentage of students performing at
meets and above has not returned to its
precoid levels.
Um on the top chart here you will see
the breakdown um of student performance
on the star 3 through 8 disagregated by
their economically disadvantaged status.
Um and the same for star EOCC's on the
bottom chart
for star 3 through 8 23% of students who
are economically disadvantaged achieved
meets grade level or better. um while
72% of students who are not economically
disadvantaged achieved meets grade level
or better. And for STAR EOC 33% of
students who are economically
disadvantaged achieved meets grade level
or better while 83% of students who are
not economically disadvantaged achieved
uh meets grade level or uh better. Data
shows significant disparity in
achievement between our economically
disadvantaged students and their peers.
Um this has been top of mind for us. Um
and this is why sup uh the
superintendent worked to develop and
implement the support and resource index
uh to prioritize supporting campuses
with the highest needs including
staffing instructional coaches and
content interventionists at those
campuses. Uh we recognize that there is
a lot of work to be done here to bridge
the uh gap uh and to ensure every
student regardless of their background
um has the support and resources they
need to succeed. Supporting our students
who are economically disadvantaged will
continue to be a focus for us as we move
forward.
And at this time we're available to
answer any questions.
>> Thank you. I appreciate all of this.
Thank you. I appreciate all of this
information very much. Um, it is uh
interesting to see it all kind of put in
one place. I have a text from Ashley
that says, "This is student outcomes and
the same rules reply for goal
monitoring." She says, "Not an
appropriate time for advice or
opinions." Um, but regular questions
apply. And I do want to just um call out
that there are some it's great to see
some bright spots and some improvement
and some rebounding uh in a lot of areas
um after some dips. So that is exciting
to see and I I know we've been talking
about kind of investment investments
making a difference and and it is nice
to see that progress especially you know
for our students who are mastering and
for does not meets going down where
we're seeing that in a lot of different
places. So thank you for that. Um the
trustees, do we have questions?
>> Um thank you so much for this uh
presentation. Super helpful. Um do we
have a sense of how we're um how the
state overall has been doing? Like are
we following patterns similar to the
state? because I know the state has, you
know, they showed some improvements in
reading overall and some decline, you
know, maybe declines in math. Um, and so
just wanted to get a little bit and are
we and by the way, President Boswell,
can we ask these these practical like
clarifying questions or do they have to
be LSG approved?
>> I don't have an answer to that question.
I can get one.
>> Okay. Well,
>> so I mean I guess I I'll answer. Um so
there have been uh certainly uh some
areas where the we have not kept up with
the state and there areas that where
we've beat the state.
>> Um you know breaking it down group by
group. I don't necessarily recall kind
of where that was the case but I will
say that it goes both ways. Um and so I
can provide another supplemental report
or I know Dylan if you want to speak to
a couple of the things that you've
observed. Um that would be fine. I I I
suspect that's an okay question to
respond to.
>> Apparently it was.
>> Okay.
Yeah, we're underperforming the state
when it comes to our students with the
label of economically disadvantaged. Um,
we tend to be on par or higher than the
state when we look at our percentage of
students at mastery and that would vary
by subject. And we tend to be on par
with the state when we're looking at
meets and above. So that's meets and
mastery combined. Um but our failure
rates overall when we're looking at um
combined results tend to be higher than
the state and that's driven by the
performance of our students that have a
label of economically disadvantaged in
most cases.
>> Okay, I appreciate that. Um we do and I
I appreciate um Josh you're sending some
of the like the tool the underlying tool
for this and there are some interesting
results um and I want to make sure I'm
interpreting interpreting this correctly
but um it looks like for
actually I'm just going to hold my
tongue because I'm not sure I'm
interpreting this correctly but I I
would really be interested in um having
a more detailed analysis
by student group and maybe we can wait
until the taper comes out. That usually
comes out like in October, right?
>> December
>> or December. Okay. Then I'll just I'll
just wait till that comes out to do my
other
>> questions. So, thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional questions, Trusty
Kintana.
>> Thank you.
um given what we know about these scores
now and the disparities
um and between certain student groups,
how are we going to speed up the
process? Um I know we've had a lot of
conversations about um instructional
coaches and content interventionists.
But aside from that, do we have anything
else?
>> Yeah. So, I would say that um making
sure that this organization supports
historically underserved student groups
um one of the largest of which is
students that are identified as
economics advantage is is like my core
like purpose for being in this role. Um
what I would say is given the number of
students that we have um roughly I think
56% depending 55% depending on kind of
what we get it's really where we're
about 45 55 um there's been a lot that's
been going and putting put in place I
would say right now it's about fidelity
of implementation in these areas so I
would say the first one being is um one
big one is MTSS uh multi-ter system of
support. So over the last year uh we've
been um steadfast in ensuring that we
are uh we have a system that truly
tells us where our students are. Are
they on grade level? Are they not? If do
they need interventions? If so, um how
do we have the resources in place? Uh
whether it's an educator with the right
curriculum to leverage or a content
interventionist coming in to do a small
group. Uh where where is that gap? And
so I would say that in 2425 we were just
getting started because the really in 23
24 is when that system came in. Uh it
took root um I think say most notably
ear in the early grades and now we're
expanding it into secondary um quite
significantly. Uh so that is a big area
of focus for us. So that's one. So I do
expect this year to be a significant
significant movement in that area which
will help much of this. The other thing
I would say is um our curriculum is is
finally I think becoming more aligned um
to ensure that our students who are who
have been most historically underserved
maybe even have high mobility rates um
aren't impacted because we are not
providing the resources to our campuses
or to our teachers. Um so that's big
number two. I think the SRRI this um
support resource index is something that
we produced in 2324. Yes, last year we
introduced it. it kind of was it was
brought into the system. And just to
provide an overview what this is, every
single um school has a an SRRI um index
rating. And we organize it by band. If
you're in band one, you um are a school
that um has a stu a high number of
students who have historically been
underserved. And what that means is that
the resources we deploy, how we level,
um how we hire, how we um allocate
additional funds are all prioritized in
that way. And we've seen that actually
be reflected in just how we've hired
like the way that we started this year.
I was talking to principles just today
and yesterday. They were able to hire
and staff, you know, weeks if not months
before they had previously. So all of
these things are contributing. Um I
would say right now the focus is making
sure we have the resources to continue
and actually reinforce things that are
not um being done with fidelity. Uh
which is why the just in time
professional development is a big um
area of focus. It's why we need to find
resources honestly um to continue the
work. Uh, so I would say those are the
three big things um that I would say
were introduced in 2425,
but really with what we're doing now,
the fidelity component is really what
you're going to see move the needle. And
I expect that to be the case. I mean, in
2023, we had 30FS. In 2024, we had 29.
In 2025, we have 23. Um, and I I will
expect that to continue to come down.
And what we're keeping a really close
eye on are those schools who've been
historically underserved to make sure
they get what they need to be
successful. Um, so those are the things
I would say.
>> Thank you. Additional questions.
>> Trusty Hunter.
>> Sorry if we can go to slide 13.
Excellent. Thank you. um
showing some growth in
the masters. How will the district
ensure measurable improvement in 8th
grade social studies performance um
since there has been no significant
improvement in meets from 2022 to 2025?
Let's
say you're Dr. Wilson
probably.
>> Do you want me to repeat the question or
No, it's okay. I was listening.
>> Okay.
>> Um, so I I think social studies really
is is is one of the topics we don't get
the opportunity to talk about as much.
We focus a lot on reading and a lot on
math. Um, fortunately I think there has
been a I'll say a shift in the way we
teach language arts. So it's not just
focused and especially uh right now as
we've moved to high quality
instructional materials so that it's not
just focused on genre but it is focused
on the world. So a lot of science text a
lot of social studies text things like
that. So I think just even the shift
towards um high quality instructional
materials really will make a difference.
Um, social studies is also the one of
the areas that our um, our academics
team is working on putting together.
There's not um, as much focus on high
quality instructional materials as
social studies as well coming to us and
that are being actually produced um, by
um, uh, publishers and things that are
even available in open resources. And so
we do have to curate a lot of things in
order to make sure that they have what
they need. Um but our academics team has
been working on um providing some really
structured supports and lessons in
social studies so that they have a
curriculum that guides them or resources
that they can use and a curriculum that
actually guides them and some lessons
that guide them in using it. So that's
definitely been a structure that's put
in place, but I think it's really kind
of the just the big picture of um not
always leaving social studies and
learning about the world to the social
studies classroom, but that it's
integrated um and we're using those
opportunities to do it.
>> Okay. Um you mentioned uh HQIM, small
HQIM. Um so we don't think about the
other one. People freak out when I say
the other one, but small hqim and um the
question I have here is
we talked about that we don't have them
that we're having to curate it. So
that's kind of like what is and so my
question is how are we going to address
this gap, right? So what we're doing now
is we do we have curated a lot of those
materials and in putting them together
have also structured lessons for
teachers to be able that offer more
structure rather than them having to
pull it all together um and look at
resources and things like that to try to
you know put it pull it together
themselves.
>> Okay. Um and how long has that been
going on? So we get so I'm trying to see
how when when I should see a shift.
Right.
>> This year.
>> So it's starting this year. Now there's
always implementation. It takes a little
bit, but we're, you know, starting to
see some of those results, our early
grade levels as well. Um, I had the
opportunity to spend a couple days this
week with middle 12 middle school
campuses teachers as well with some of
these trainings and using the materials,
which um is always a great um
opportunity and way to really help
implementation. Um, but yeah, we're
starting that this year with those
additional structured supports.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Sure.
>> Thank you. We have uh trustee deoste.
>> Um could we go to slide 19 please?
>> Sorry just to flesh out the context for
this question you know when I look at
this the disparity is really obvious. Um
but
you know in this conversation I think it
it's easy to presume campuses that are
extremely high uh socioeconomic
disadvantaged students but clearly some
of these students are going to the same
campus right that are on both of these
bar graphs and they're receiving the
same level of fidelity the same general
instruction um presumably at both of
those campuses you know aside from maybe
specific class changes um course course
changes. So I'm curious what more are we
looking at besides just the
instructional materials and the fidelity
um for p performance variance between
these students? You know the you know
are we looking at like campuses why
those populations might be performing so
differently besides just the
implementation of the instruction. Um
I'm I'm sure I I taught at a title one
school and you know we had a magnet
program. you know that that's a
difference between some of the
instruction that the students are coming
but I'm curious how many of these
students are kind of in the same
classroom getting the same experience
and still performing differently. How do
we address that type of issue?
>> Good evening.
You're asking aside from just the high
quality instructional materials and
curriculum documents, what other
variances impact
>> what more we can look at or you know
because presumably some of these
students in the 44.4
that are mastering are in the same
classroom as as students that are not
meeting standards. So they're receiving
the exact same instruction. Not
obviously not all of them, but some of
them are. And so what besides the
elements that we've discussed are we
looking at to help bridge that gap?
>> Yes. Um I think one of the things we're
playing we're paying really close
attention to this school year is um this
idea of scaffolding at times what we're
noticing in classrooms is that if we see
that a student or you know a number of
students may be behind when it comes to
reading level or grade level we may
spend the entire class period um
teaching to a level of instruction that
is below the grade level instruction and
never scaffold to that intended point of
learning for student mastery. And so
what we are doing now is being very
intentional on our walks and being very
intentional in our planning and PD like
Dr. Maxwell mentioned on Monday and
Tuesday to acknowledge that yes there
are some prerequisite skills and some
knowledge gaps that we may need to
address but we don't spend the entire
block teaching to that. We see the
finish line and then we backwards design
plan and teach that intended learning a
master. So yes, scaffold, yes, small
groupoup instruction, interventions, um
differentiated with lessons and
instructional strategies, but also not
reducing the level of rigor in order for
students to be successful because if we
continually teach below grade level,
students will never be able to access
grade level content and show mastery in
those areas.
>> And and so is the thought with that
approach with scaffolding that that
would carry over to when they're
actually taking the STAR test? like
those are elements that are going to be
able to carry over in the testing
environment.
>> Yes, absolutely.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional questions. Trusty
Willy Chu.
>> Um yes. So, um I noticed on slide seven
that our
sixth and eighth grade scores um
increased more significantly
um than any other uh grade level.
And um I wanted to know um why we saw
such growth in in those reading grade
levels.
I will start and um Dr. Maxwell will
will tag team me if I'm not hitting the
mark. What I will say historically and
this is not just in our district but
across the state and I would argue
across the country as well, seventh
grade is a very particular grade and
it's hard to staff um teachers in
seventh grade. It's um an interesting
time of year um with students. Um, so we
are paying close attention to seventh
grade. We've noticed that seventh grade
normally has the lower scores when it
comes to math achievement. Um, and we
normally see dips or that they are just
maintaining and not increasing at that
level. And so in our PLC's, in our PDS
um, and even in our planning with
principles like we have our eye on
seventh grade to ensure that we see that
intended level of mastery. Also, what we
are noticing historically as well is
that when students are placed in
advanced placement classes, let's say
eighth grade algebra or other um tracks,
they tend to take the star for that
grade level. And so, it may not be as
much representation at the seventh grade
level because there are students that
are seated in seventh grade seats that
are taking, let's say, eighth grade star
algebra, taking ELC for higher um tested
areas in the advanced placement track
and pathways. Um, but specifically
speaking to sixth grade uh performance
in math and eighth grade performance in
sixth and eighth grade and in math and
reading, those were areas that we
focused on last year. Um,
as far as the instructional content for
systems, but it it wasn't necessarily
parsed out for seventh grade. So, I
couldn't tell you specifically why not
seventh grade, but from a historical
standpoint, that is not a surprise to
me.
>> Thank you so much.
Thank you. Additional questions.
All right, I have just a couple. Um, on
slide six,
um, middle school English one, I think,
uh, anytime I see fluctuations like I'm
seeing in this slide, that really makes
me curious about what's really going on
and makes me wonder how reliable we
think that uh, the information that this
is giving us is. And I would love to
understand um what your thoughts are
about why we saw you know that that real
strength in 2023, that big fall off in
2024.
Um you know with with zero does not meet
in 2023 and then a big fall off in 2024
and and obviously big growth again in
2025 not to where we were in 2023. But
um would really love to understand what
we're seeing and why we think that's the
pattern we're seeing.
>> I can get a
>> or lack of pattern.
>> This is a very small sample size. Uh we
don't have many middle schools that have
English one.
>> Um and so you will see those kinds of
fluctuations uh even with one or two
students.
>> Yeah, this represents the results of one
campus that does EOCC uh English one in
middle school. Like so for 23 there was
se that represents seven tests. In 24
it's 17 tests and in 25 six tests. So
whenever you have that few a number of
tests you know just two or three changes
is going to cause a large change in
terms of percentages.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. And then
um I'd love to look at um slides 11 and
uh where I think looking at the star for
fifth grade and eighth grade together
for science. Um, as you point out, we
saw um, you know, the beginning of an
increase um, after it had decreased over
the years and and um, back you know, a
tiny bit higher than we were in 2023
when the new test went um, came into
play. And then I think when you look at
slide 12, you really see um most of that
growth was with our eighth graders and
would really love to understand um kind
of what you think we're seeing
especially in that fifth grade um
science and especially in a community
where as we're looking ahead for kids
taking career and technical education.
We know high quality certifications,
there's, you know, science is a big
field in our community. um you know,
kind of what we're seeing and and what
we're doing to address that that lower
performance in science, especially in
fifth grade.
>> Thank you, Dr. Maxwell.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. So, um, fifth grade, of course,
being the first year that, uh, science
is tested, um, it and and I I appreciate
you explaining, you know, the
differences in the in the assessment
over the over the last few years. Uh,
there have been significant changes in
the assessment and in in the standards,
in the way that we teach the science
standards. So in fifth grade really what
we started to do last year was um ch it
was actually first year of a new adopted
resource um for science instruction and
so we raill wrote curriculum guiding
documents that really um again you know
supported teachers in the usage of those
materials. Um, and then we also have a
team that uh works for um creating all
of our science kits for classrooms. And
so they do they put together tens of
thousands of science kits. I just want
to plug that team right now. They they
are incredibly hardworking. Um they do
an amazing job putting hands-on learning
experiences together for students in the
classroom. And we shipped those out very
regularly last year. um brought them
back um to our center, packaged the
repackaged things, shipped the next ones
out to go along with the units um that
went with our um science adoption. I
will say we do that in-house as a
district because it is a fraction of the
cost as what it would be to actually
order all those materials from the
publisher. Um, and so that it's just a
service that, you know, a saving service
that we provide, but also just wanted to
make sure that even though they're very
expensive, um, we could find a way to do
it and get those learning experiences
out to campuses. So, that's a big um,
support that should always go with
science. Also, we've paid a lot of
attention to whether or not science is
being taught consistently and vertically
through the classrooms. um it's super
easy to focus on on uh literacy and math
in the early grade levels, not as much
on science and social studies and it's
really critical to give them these
science kids are K5 so it's really
critical to give them them those
experiences as well. Um and then um have
increased some professional learning
around science as well. It was an area
um of focus when we pulled
administrators this summer at the at the
leadership institute and they actually
got the hands-on experiences that are in
the classroom. So they had they enjoyed
that. They had a lot of fun with it. Um
and then teachers got to do do the same
at the beginning of the year. So we
didn't just train on math, we trained on
STEM. So they had opportunities and
hours to really dig into um the
resources, get lessons prepared um and
also take a good look at what was coming
up in the year. So again, not a thing
that we get to talk about as much, but
we're doing a lot of the same work to
improve that in fifth grade.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. Um, any
further questions?
>> All right. Thank you all for this
presentation. Thank you for the report.
Um, we are now moving to our consent
agenda. And before we do that, we are
going to pull a few items for a separate
vote based on our conversation at the
information session last week. Um these
are deliverables that we owe um under
our agreed order to um bring everything
into compliance um so we can fully um
check off some things on our um self
monitoring, our self uh evaluation. Uh,
it's item 10.3, approval of updates to
the district scorecard and targets.
10.4, approval of updates to the board
monitoring calendar. 10.5, approval of
amendments to the board guard rails.
10.6, approval of amendments to the
board handbook. And in addition, the
administration has pulled agenda item
14.1, GF local, public complaints for
further legal review, and 16.2, two,
termination of non-chapter 21 contract
employee during the contract term uh
with the initials.
Uh trustees, any other consent items to
pull for a separate vote.
Uh Vice President Willy Chu, do I have a
motion to approve the consent agenda?
Yes. I move to approve
items,
item 8.1,
items 9.1
through 9.3.
Items
10.1,
10.2 2
>> and items 10.6 through 10.11
>> and we're pulling 10.6 so it'll be 10.7.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Double checking
while you read. Thank you.
>> Items 10.7
through 10.11.
Items 11.1 through 11.4.
Items 12.1
through 12.3.
Items item 13.1.
>> Item 14.1 and 14.2.
>> Yeah, not 14.1. Just
>> we're gonna Okay,
>> we're going to pull 14.1. Okay. Um,
items 14.2
>> and then 17. And then we have items for
separate vote. So those were good later.
Okay. Thank you. All right. Is there a
second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh trustees, any discussion
on these items?
All right. Um having a motion to approve
uh by Vice President Whitley Chu and a
second by Trustee Kintana to approve uh
agenda items 8.1, 9.1 through 9.3, 10.1
through 10.2. 2, 10.7 through 10.11,
11.1 through 11.4, 12.1 through 12.3,
item 13.1, and item 14.2.
All those in favor, please raise your
right hands.
And the motion passes by all those on
the dis 8 to Z. Um, and now we will move
to items pulled from the agenda. Um we
will start
>> the extension items.
>> The abstension items. Um yeah, let's go
ahead and do the abstension items and
then we'll do that. Does that work?
Okay, let's go ahead and do the
abstension items. So we have um
abstension items for a separate vote. Do
we have a motion to approve item 14 uh
15.1?
>> Yes. I move to approve agenda item 15.1
um 2025 through 2020 through 2030 school
year approval of an educational
experience agreement between the
University of Texas at Austin social
work program and Austin ISD. Thank you.
Do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh is there any discussion?
All right. Having a motion by Vice
President Willie Chu and a second by
Trustee Kintana to approve agenda item
15.1. All those in favor, please raise
your right hand.
Any opposed?
Any abstensions?
Uh that passes
uh
eight no seven in favor and zero
opposed. Two abstension. No, six in
favor. Sorry. Oh, yep. Yes, because
we're missing one. Six in favor, zero
opposed, and two abstensions with Trusty
Kaufman and Trustee Foster abstaining.
Um, do I have a motion to approve item
15.2?
>> Yes. I move to approve agenda item 15.2,
2025 to 2026, renewal of interlocal
agreement with the University of Texas
for literacy first.
>> Do I have a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh, is there any discussion?
>> Yes. I just want to thank um the
district for continuing this awesome
program. It shows great results and it's
one of the few that has a randomized
control trial to show its effectiveness
and I really do appreciate um the
commitment to excellence that we have
with this program and the program's
commitment to excellence to our
students. So, thank you.
>> Thank you. Any further discussion or
comment?
>> All right. Having a motion from uh vice
president Lily Chu to approve item point
uh 15.2 with a second by trustee
Kintana. All in favor raise your right
hand. Any opposed? Any abstaining? And
again we have six in favor, zero opposed
and two abstaining with trustees Kaufman
and Foster abstaining. Uh moving on to
15.3. Do I have a motion? Yes. Yes. I
move to approve agenda item 15.3 2025 to
2026 interlocal agreement with the
University of Texas for literacy first
district capacity building model.
>> Thank you. Do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh is there any discussion?
All right. Having a motion by vice
president, a second by trustee Kintana
to approve agenda item 15.3. All in
favor, please raise your right hand.
Any opposed?
any abstaining and again we have six uh
votes in favor two abstensions with
trustee Kaufman and Foster abstaining
and moving on to 15.4 vice president
will you move to approve agenda item
15.4 for approval of an interlocal
agreement between the University of
Texas at Austin and Austin ISD for on
the on ranch program.
>> Thank you.
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh any discussion?
All right. Having a motion by Vice
President Willie Chu and a second by
Trustee Kintana to approve item 15.4.
All in favor, please raise your right
hand. Any opposed?
Any abstaining? And we have six. Uh
Trusty Foster, are you abstaining? We
have six in favor with two abstensions
with trustee Foster and Trustee Kaufman
again uh to approve item 15.4.
We can come back to um our 16 items
since those are for separate separate
vote. We'll go back um to our items
under section 10 board administration.
Um
and we will start with uh 10.3. The
first item that has been pulled,
approval of updates to our district
scorecard and targets. Do I have a
motion to approve 10.3? I move to
approve item 10.3 by reducing the number
of goals to three and striking goals
four and five and by reducing the number
of constraints to one, striking
constraints
one through four.
Okay. Do we have a second?
>> Could you restate?
>> Yes. I move to approve item 10.3 by
reducing the number of goals to three,
striking goals four and five,
and by reducing the number of
constraints to one, striking constraints
one through four, and keeping constraint
five.
>> Thank you. I second.
>> Okay. Uh trustees, any discussion?
Trusty Kaufman. Um I appreciate the
narrowing of the number of items to
focus on through our constraints and our
goals. Um but I per our discussion last
week I am in favor of the
proposed goals and constraints and GPMs
that are in the posted agenda. So I
would prefer not to strike
goal number five. I mean goal number
four. I prefer not to strike um the
constraints.
>> TR President Boswell, could we ask folks
to actually say what that constrain or
goal relates to as they're saying it?
So,
>> so we're not talking just in numbers
certainly. So, the Yeah, I will say the
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> I say in this in the context of what I
would like to keep in it. Okay. Uh so I
would like to maintain goal number four
related to middle school algebra because
of the importance of our students
continuing into
um I'd like to have that discussion at
least. I understand there's pros and
cons to keeping that. Um more
importantly on the constraints I would
like I'd like the prefer the um the
revised constraints that include
constraint one on underserved students
specifically around special education
evaluations and exclusionary discipline.
The proposal here um has taken out one
of the constraint progress measures that
was previously in there. So, it's
reduced already to two under constraint
number one. Um constraint number two I
prefer keeping in there which is under
care. Well, okay. You know what? I
strike my comment. Um I would just like
to um there are certain constraints I
would like to keep in here. I'm going to
rephrase my comments and and state them
after other people have a chance to
talk.
>> Thank you. Additional comments.
Can you go back to that question though
about resetting what they are all about?
I didn't I think the the request was to
go ahead and say what is what are all
these that we're talking about keeping
and
>> Oh, sure. And I didn't do that.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so the motion is to keep um our three
required goals under Lone Star
Governments. Goal one is third grade
literacy. Goal two is third grade
numeracy. And goal three is college
career military readiness. To strike
goal four, which is middle school
algebra
um to strike goal five, which we already
um do not have. That was our seal of
biiteracy. And we um at our um that is
not on what's been put into board docs
today. we had discussed already last
week losing that one. Um and then on the
superintendent constraints, uh the
motion is to get rid of constraint one
under for underserved students. Um which
is measured by special education
evaluations and um whether we have
outstanding um special pending special
education evaluations that exceed
required timelines and also about
exclusionary discipline uh across
different demographic groups. Constraint
number two to strike our caregiver
engagement that is um developing a plan
within the campus improvement plan based
on um dual capacity framework. Con uh
strike constraint dual three uh
constraint three for dual language about
um a walkth through and the language of
instruction. Strike constraint four
about early learning and developmentally
inappropriate practices. And then keep
constraint five which is accountability.
um about unacceptable ratings of three
or more based on the current uh A
throughF accountability system to keep
number five and strike the rest of the
constraints. And I'd like to um just as
we're having this discussion clarify
that um there was some confusion about
the constraints and how they are counted
under the lonear government governance
time um
that we are we are working with and um
the 50% that our agreed order requires
and goals count as student outcomes
time, constraints count as adult focus
time. Um
and so we cannot talk directly about
that A throughF accountability system.
Um and and F ratings. Um that is
considered adult focus time. Um to talk
about that and and that was you know we
wanted to put it the reason we had
talked about putting it as a constraint
was to have a regular cadence of
monitoring but that time does count a
student outcomes focus time under the
Lonear governance system. So does that
uh clarify where we are and what we what
the motion is
and is there further? So I think um
Trusty Kaufman has expressed that uh he
uh would like something different from
the motion um and and for algebra to
remain and and some questions about the
constraints. Do we have
>> all my specific I I there are other
pieces I would like to keep in there but
I'm retracting my specifics that I
stated.
>> Okay. until such time as I hear from
other trustees and I'll restate my
opinion.
>> Thank you Trusty Singh.
>> Um so for the goals um I'm
I think I agree with Trusty Kaufman. Um
which is to keep the third grade the
three that we're required to keep one
through three. Um the literacy third
grade literacy third grade math and the
CCMR one. And then um I would want to
keep the middle school algebra. Um and
the reason for that is we I know we're
doing that work anyway. And so and it is
critical. And if you look at um our star
data, it's actually even though we're
making some gains there, um middle
school math is actually where it seems
like we're performing the worst. Um, and
so I want to just be able to track that
really closely. And moreover, it does
count as student outcomes minutes is my
understanding if it's a goal. And I
think that any time, you know, we spend
talking about
things that, um, whatever TEA will allow
us to talk about here, um, I think we
should maximize that. Um although at the
same time um goal three uh the goal
around um the seal of biiteracy goal
five as I described last week in the
board meeting um I would be okay letting
that one drop off in exchange for
keeping um the constraint related to
dual language implementation. Um and I
did want to add one more thing I thought
of related to the dual language
implementation. Our board policy, I
believe, actually requires us to have a
board briefing on how we're doing with
the with the dual language
implementation every year. So either
way, we're going to get that briefing
and my opinion is might as well keep it
as a as a constraint. Um, and then I
also wanted to keep the constraint
around um
the new one, the the accountability one.
So, thank you um President Boswell for
working with um with Ashley on on
getting that one in there.
Um so yeah I want to keep constraint the
new constraint five
um constraint three which is around goal
language uh dual language and um
you know
I I can't remember Katherine was was
your original um motion to strike the
underserved students one constraint one
My motion was to keep, excuse me, to
keep one constraint.
So the number five. Okay. Just number
five. Okay. So just Okay. Um I'm not
I think I'm good with that. Um just
keeping constraint three and five
um are probably the two constraints I
would like to keep. And then I would
like to keep con goal one, two, three
and um and four which is the algebra.
Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional questions or
conversation comments? Trusty state.
>> Um yeah, I would say that I am in
agreement to go down to the three goals.
Um, and for the middle school, I think
my rationale is based on the my
understanding of the reporting
requirement. And if there's just one
yearly progress measure, I reporting on
it several times doesn't doesn't seem
valuable. Um, regarding the constraints,
I would like to keep constraint one. Um,
I'm okay cutting 1.1 the absentee, but
the
>> guess these these are dupes.
>> Yeah. Um but the well the draft that I
see um regarding special education
evaluations and exclusionary discipline,
I think those are both ones that are
valuable to the community and kind of
fit the spirit of what a constraint
would be uh as opposed to the
conversation that we had last session
about constraints being additional
goals. These actually do seem like
constraints to me. Um, and then I'm in
favor of keeping the dual language since
we're cutting the goal around dual
language and constraint five.
>> Thank you. Additional comments.
>> Um, I move to divide the motion.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> In what way?
So I move to
>> would I state the two separate motions
need to have a live motion. So do you
want to amend your do you want to amend
the motion that's on the floor or do you
want to withdraw it and make a new one
perhaps?
>> Sure.
>> Um I will withdraw the motion.
>> I move to withdraw the motion.
And
>> and so to divide the motion, can I
>> it might be appropriate to ask if
there's any objection to the withdrawal
of the motion.
>> Is there any objection to withdrawing
the motion?
>> Okay, see no objections. Uh are you
ready to make a new motion, Vice
President? Really?
>> Yes.
>> I'm almost ready. Okay.
Right. I move to approve item 10.3
by reducing the number of goals to three
and striking goals four and five.
Okay. And that and then we'll come back
to the constraint section. Yes, we're
just approving the beginning of that.
Okay.
>> Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you, Trusty Hunter. Okay. Is there
any further discussion
on the motion to approve? We're just
talking about the goals now. Approve the
three that are required. Goal one, third
grade literacy. Goal two, third grade
numeracy. And goal three, college career
and military readiness. And to approve
uh remove uh goal four. Trusty Kaufman.
Uh, I would just like to ask our
superintendent again what the
administration opinion is around the
value of goal four on middle school
algebra in advancing um our goals as a
district.
And I ask that in the spirit of knowing
that we have a shared interest in this
goal in the progress of our students in
achieving high level math. But I also
want to be very thoughtful about the
extent to which our goals and our
constraints help move the work forward
versus the extent to which our goals and
constraints put um undue demands on the
administration and overload the work
that we're doing. So I just wanted to go
back to the conversation we had last
week and get your um administration
opinion on whether goal four is
something that would meaningfully move
the work forward in your opinion.
Um,
so, uh, Trusty Foster, given that gulf
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry.
>> He's he's talking to you, Kevin. It's
okay.
>> I closed my eyes when I was about to do
this response, so I just like I'm like
in a
>> We look the same when your eyes are
closed.
Um so my response would be that um what
trusted said regarding having one goal
progress measure tied to one goal does
create kind of challenges with how we
report. Um given the work that we've
seen over the last year in our focus on
uh middle school math, algebra most
notably and the law, I I'm very
confident that we the work is not going
to slow down. We are hyperfocused on
being um successful uh in making sure
that our students achieve academically
um in middle school math. uh but what I
shared last time is very true in that
every time I present or we present to
the trustees requiring the fact that we
have to rep you know we have to report
multiple times a year and that it's one
goal progress measure it it does feel
performative um and I and I we're not
going to present something that isn't
useful to our trustees and so that does
require you know
effort um it just
Okay. And so um so my opinion on goal
four is that because it is um already
addressed in some way by the stateled
law that requires us to have um more
students enrolled in advanced
mathematics which sets kids on the
pathway towards algebra 1 since algebra
1 success rates are already part of the
accountability system on the EOC and
which is you know tied to the successful
performance in class. I feel like this
one can be addressed through other
measures. And then going back to my
concern around the limitation of our
goal setting, um a goal of increasing
from 8% of our economically
disadvantaged students um succeeding in
algebra 1 in 8th grade by in June 2024
and five years later to increase that to
14%.
That doesn't move the needle, right?
That's fewer than you know that's
probably fewer than 50 kids. So in five
years, this goal is compelling us to
increase the number of economically
disadvantaged students who are in and
successful in algebra 1 by roughly 50 or
something kids by my back of the
envelope math. So I don't think it's
worth keeping this goal in there for
that reason.
>> Trusty Singh.
>> Yeah. Um I appreciate the conversation.
when we report on
the on the goals um
from you know we talk about not just the
data of like how many students are
enrolled we're looking at outlier
schools we're looking at um you know
other factors that are part of you know
you know this is an opportunity for us
to talk about the basic academic program
that would be at every school and if
we're if the, you know, administration
is,
you know, it's a way for us to check
progress on that through the lens of
mathematics.
Um, it also, you know, as long as we're
under LSG, I'll just be frank, it does
it does allow us more time to talk about
student outcomes in a very specific way,
and a meaningful way. Um, and so what I
would I although at the same time I
don't want to create an extra reporting
burden on our staff who are already
doing so much. Um, but I'm wondering if
maybe we can think about when we're
reporting this, maybe we're reporting
different aspects of this, like you
know, one time when you're reporting it,
you're talking about the outlier
schools. the next time you're talking
about, you know, other strategies that
you all are doing or, you know, so it's
not like you have to do everything like
the Cadillac version of the report three
times. I'm not sure if that's something
that you all would consider.
>> So, so whatever the board decides to do,
I we will do just to be clear. Um I I I
mean, of course, you know, I think just
the monitoring report has just changed,
so we're limited to five pages. I have
to have a longitudinal graph. I have to
have a superintendent's assessment of
whether we're on track or off track. You
know, there there are lots of things
that are required by LSG to be included
in the report. And so I'm happy to
figure out a way to kind of lean into
different things. Um but the report
itself that now we have to produce
>> does have specific elements. Um, and I
and so I I just don't know how much
flexibility I have in how I report. If
I'm thinking about the structure, you
know, I there are just
>> No, that's helpful. I hear you're saying
I hear what you're saying. So what what
to summarize, it sounds like the the the
constraints that TEA is is imposing on
on the way we report this is actually
causing us to take our eyes off the ball
of advanced math. That those are my
words, not your words. Yeah,
>> superintendent. I'm But but like that's
I just want to be clear that's what it
feels like to me. Um I'm still going to
support including this goal. I may I may
be outvoted and I'm cool with that, but
I just feel like it's hard for for me to
be in the seat and and say I'm not going
to track
middle school math because
um of a a flawed reporting requirement
that's being imposed on us. So, I'll
leave it at that. And and I think um
what I offered at the last board meeting
and I'm happy to offer at any point is
we're happy to to share our work and
provide reports and board updates and if
if we need to we can post them. Um I I
just so I I think what you're perhaps
suggesting we can definitely
accommodate. I just don't know I can
accommodate in this structure. Um so if
it's a if that's where the board ends up
we're happy to accommodate. it's in the
board uh scorecard. I'm happy to do it.
But I think in either case, the work is
in progress. We are going to monitor.
We're going to share our work. Um that
that's my expectation, our expectation
of the team, and we've made that clear.
>> Thank you. Any further discussion?
Trusty Foster.
>> Sure. Um
in order to to function
as a professor, I have responsibilities
for teaching, research, and service.
I work most effectively and efficiently
when I can bring those into seamless
into seamlessness and my the teaching
that I do also has a service dimension.
The research that I do involves my
students etc. like try to bring these
together. Um likewise, if I'm teaching
and I have to give uh an assessment a
test, um I'm best served if that
assessment simultaneously advances
learning. That is to say, this
assessment isn't just time away where
the kid the students have memorized
something, they dump it out, and we move
on never to return. rather I'd love to
see something Socratic or something
where um the students actually gain in
the process of the assessment. I give
those two examples to say that
in a moment when we have a ton of
turnaround plans, we have a fiscal cliff
and consolidations and we have reduced
central office staff and we have uh just
a ton of stuff going on
with fewer and fewer resources. If the
administration says to me that
it is going to be hard to continue to do
the work while we have to take time
aside in generating the reporting and if
we can't find a way for the reporting
and the scorecard work to be sort of
synergistic to the process and rather
the reporting work is time away from
campuses for administrators and time
away from conversations and efforts that
are sort of critical to the mission. Um
if we if those can't be brought together
then we are in a moment where we have to
in a sense exercise both some faith that
that that is hard because we have a
monitoring responsibility
um but exercise some faith of saying
look go and do the work um and we won't
have the check-ins the same exact way. I
think the ask of the administration then
would be that the administration is
completely open to our other channels
that are sort of within our framework
like our tracker and like our one-on-
ones and like our conversations like our
campus visits. Um so that we can
continue to monitor the work in a way
that's you know in line with state
expectations.
Um, so like a a little bit of a give
in both directions. But for me, um, I I
see our situation is dire in terms of
we have not had the collapse of morale.
In fact, our morale has been going in
the right direction for some time now.
And I want to honor that. I want to
protect that. I want to listen to that.
And so for me,
although it is hard,
um it's really hard. I have this strong
preference of following what I'm
perceiving to be the recommendation to
reduce the scorecard items from five to
three.
>> Thank you. Additional comments or
questions?
>> I just want to update my back of the
envelope math. Um, actually I it's
around 181 students increase over five
years, not 50. So still 30 a year that
we're adding to the algebra one success
pile.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that. Trusty
Hunter.
>> Thank you. Um I'm just going to echo
what um Trustee Foster said in that it
is right now and I feel it everything
everywhere all at once that we are
doing. Um, but my expectation is that
the work is continuing and one of the
channels that I plan to use is that
one-on-one because I do want to know
because I have two outlier schools that
do pretty darn good when it comes to
algebra 1, right? And so I want to know
that those students who fall into the
category of um,
economically disadvantaged, which is
what the state calls it, right? I just
call it other advantaged, but
economically disadvantaged students. I
want to ensure that those numbers are
increasing that those students in those
two outlier schools, middle schools that
I have, those numbers are increasing and
it's not just being select kids
cherrypicked. It's like we believe it.
You're here. We want to get you there.
So, while I don't want to spend
resources,
much rather have more tap meetings, but
I don't want to spend resources on that.
I do my expectation is that those that
work is still occurring and that it will
should I ask it's being reported out
those numbers are at your fingertips and
you would be able to to give those to
us. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Additional questions or
comments.
>> Um so I will uh a few things. I I feel
like we have responded in part to the
administration's call to reduce the
burden by taking off goal five. Um which
definitely reduces the burden and the
reporting. Um
I feel like when we were doing
engagement about the scorecard, I heard
very loudly from our community that we
want more than star scores. We want more
than standardized testing. Um that gets
into our college career military
readiness to some degree. It gets into
um in this goal really in our goal
progress measure that ambition for our
sixth graders that our sixth graders no
matter who they are and where they come
from deserve meaningful access to
advanced math curriculum to set them up
for success. And I feel like the data
are very clear that when we do um Walter
Stroop who used to live in our community
did excellent work on this in Boston
across the country that when um students
have access to algebra in 8th grade they
are more likely to enroll in college and
succeed in college. But it is it is a
predictor and a driver which is what
Lonear Governance asked us to do. I
agree with you, Trusty Kaufman, that the
numbers are tiny because of the
constraints put on us. They are larger
in that sixth grade advanced math. And
um to your point, Superintendent Sugura,
we are going to see much bigger numbers
than the percentages that are on the
scorecard right now that the reality is
going to be we hope that more than that
180 more than that small number because
kids are are engaging in this early on.
Um
I think under
to me the ideal would be to keep it in
report in a different way. I know that's
not um the coaching and the expectations
we have from Lonear Governance. I
understand they want to see a trajectory
through the year that you can follow. Um
so I you know I know it needs to fit
into the box we've been given. Um I also
we h we we have to fit into the box
we've g been given right now with
mandatory um 50% of our time talking
about a certain set of things. Um
student outcomes is really a large part
of that set and um the rules have
changed a little bit for Lonear
governance um and we're allowed to talk
about our agreed order as long as we
have our agreed order. Um we don't know
when that's going to end. that is, you
know, it's in our hands to do the work
and we are doing the work diligently and
thoughtfully and well. Um,
and we don't know when we're going to
get out and we do have taps to talk
about. We do have
um a difficult budget to talk about. We
do have school closures to talk about.
We have profoundly important things to
talk about. Um, and the less time we
spend talking about academic academic
outcomes, which is why we're here. Um,
we know that's really our goal, but we
know these other things matter too and
and feed into academic outcomes. We know
school closures, the data is very clear
that they they impact uh outcomes in
really negative ways and in the biggest
negative ways for our students who need
the most. And so I think we are um
in this very specific system where
lonear governance is being used in a way
um that isn't kind of a continuous
growth model which is my understanding
from AJ Crarabel and and Ashley that it
was intended to be and and being used in
a more rigid way that that's the system
we're living under. But if we lose this
we lose time to talk about other things
too. And I just want to really name
that. Um, I don't want make work for
anyone. Um, I also don't want to fail to
talk about something that I think our
community has said was important and
that we had a bunch of meetings saying
was important. Um, and that we're
showing actually really exciting
progress in. And I think to show that we
have that ambition for our students is
meaningful um, to me even if it's um, a
little clunky the way we need to do it.
So, um,
any further questions on this or
comments?
Okay. So, we're ready to vote. Um,
having a motion by Vice President
President Li Whitley Chu to approve item
10.3
and reduce the number of goals to three.
goal one
um
third grade literacy, goal two, third
grade numeracy, and goal three college
career and military readiness. So that
would be um approving the scorecard with
only those three goals. Having a second
by trustee Hunter for that. All in
favor, please raise your right hand.
Any opposed?
And the motion carries um by eight no
six to two. Six to two. Um so we now
have three goals. Okay. We have um the
second part of the split motion coming.
>> Yes.
I move to approve item 10.3
by reducing the number of constraints to
two
striking constraints two three and four.
Okay. Do we have a second?
>> Do you I'm sorry. Do you mind explaining
what those constraints are?
>> So um based on the discussion, there is
a lot of support for keeping um number
one and number five
and number one was
related to underserved students,
>> correct?
>> It's in the pocket. Um I don't have it
open.
>> Oh, okay. So, that was related to
special ed eval. I just want to make
sure folks know what we're voting on.
>> Yeah, let's get a second and then we can
discuss and I'll go through and read it.
>> Thank you.
>> Does that work? Do we have a second on
this?
>> Second,
>> Trusty Kintana. Okay. Um Okay. So we
have a motion from vice president Willie
Chu to approve um the second part of uh
10.3
speaking about the constraints to reduce
the constraints to two and strike
constraint number two constraint number
three and constraint number four. So we
would be keeping constraint number one
underserved students. We would be losing
constraint number two that is caregiver
engagement. we would be losing
constraint number three. That is how we
are measuring the fidelity of our dual
language programs. We would be losing
constraint number four, our early
learning um constraint and we would be
keeping constraint number five, our
accountability constraint about the uh
unacceptable ratings. Clear? Okay. Do we
have discussion?
Trustee Deuro.
>> Um
yeah, I I just want to speak for
maintaining constraint three. I know um
particularly in the meetings that have
been going on recently at the dual
language campuses considering that we've
removed the dual language goal. Um you
know there's a lot of concern as it
relates to the you know proposals that
potentially are coming uh soon. And so I
think continuing the reporting on um
historically marginized groups will
speak to the district's commitment to
follow through on the plans that we're
potentially proposing and I think it
would be um meaningful specifically to
some of those communities that are
really worried about the changes that
are potentially coming.
>> Thank you. Additional comments. Uh can
the administration explain um in in the
chart that we have in the board doc
scorecard changes 25 26 um under
constraint three there's columns it says
academic disparities
and um
the modification explanation says change
language to focus on dual language and
then it says possible but this was in
the document
Uh I'm reading that to recommend
retention
and then there's a column possible
reason for reduction desire to focus on
dual language in alignment with current
strategic focus and upcoming
consolidation changes. So with apologies
I kind of don't follow I I don't I don't
follow follow the the column. I think
there was a discussion about there being
a little bit of an overlap with goal
five uh last time and then with that
constraint and a choice of if we had to
choose just one of those to choose the
one that's in the constraints.
Okay. Um
so
constraints
sort of count against student outcomes
times and all that. So, that's kind of a
side conversation and yet, you know,
there it is. Um,
and I'm I'm I'm very sympathetic to what
Trusty Dior Estee is saying with regards
to
community perceptions really of this
whole entire action tonight. It ends up
sounding like things are now less
important. And I would love to somehow
signal loud and clear that that is
absolutely not the case. To my mind,
there is so much, not to my mind, to
reality, there is so much more that the
administration does and the district
does um that we actually pay attention
to and that is going on every day that
is well beyond five things. So, by the
way this work is done, there is tons of
stuff that's important to us and that we
actually are not low-key but high-key
monitoring in ways that meet, you know,
the expectations of the state that don't
get captured. This is a mechanism. The
scorecard thing is a mechanism that
highlights things in a particular way.
And so I want to be clear that my
discussion of the reduction of these
does not have to do with the attention
paid. Um quite the contrary. I want more
work to be freely done in these areas by
alleviating the reporting burden, which
as I'll say to reiterate is an act of
faith, right? To say, you know what, go
with God. You have work to do. I'm not
going to check in on you quite as much
on this because you really need time to
do this work. But that is not an
abdication. That is not saying, you know
what, go do what you want now. Not at
all. Um, so I'm balancing
this idea of of of alleviation of an
effort area
with the reality that these things still
need to be monitored in some way. But
then the third vector is that the
community needs to know these things are
still important. Um especially around
dual language
that is probably where I have the
greatest sort of sympathy for retention
in that there's so much swirling around
that and that is an area where we simply
in the p we're on an upward climb in
that area and and making great progress.
So, I'm most sympathetic to the
retention of that area, but I am um I'm
ready to get rid of a lot of
constraints.
>> Additional comments,
>> I was just going to say ditto
what he said.
>> Trusty Hunter,
>> I just want to clarify again the
superintendent on the Excuse me. Gosh,
words are hard in the evening. The
superintendent owns the constraints.
Correct.
>> We create the constraints and they own
the constraint progress measures
>> measures. My bad. Yes, that is correct.
>> And the constraints under the Lonear
governance system have been described to
us as the way we express our community's
values.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> I would like to ask I'm sorry. I would
like to ask a similar question last time
around the administration thoughts on
these. Last time we had some discussions
around some of these measures already
having been developed some of the
systems already in place to do the
monitoring such that it wouldn't be a
heavy lift and others that were you know
perhaps not going to make as much move
movement. So in terms of the proposed
not not necessarily just this motion but
the overall set of constraints that are
in our packet what is the administration
opinion on the value of those for moving
the work forward?
Yeah, I'm going to just kind of organize
my my thoughts um kind of around where
this discussion just recently let left
or ended um con constraint one the way
that it's been drafted the way that it's
been kind of reinforced by trusted and
others like I mean I think that that
aligns we're we're first of all we don't
have any concerns with we will do all of
this just to be clear I don't know how
many times I can say that like we the
work matters the work is going to
continue um when it comes to uh the fact
that we just completed one year of the
scorecard. Uh every constraint requires
um the administration's ability to
measure it and to report on it. Uh that
being said, constraint one, three and
five to me um like collectively
um I think are very responsive to who we
are as an organization without
introducing the significant amount of
additional work to measure the
constraint and the progress of that
constraint. constraint uh three uh
around the walkthroughs. I mean just to
give you an example uh last year was a
baseline year. Uh in the fall semester
uh principles performed the observations
at each of their campuses. Uh in the
spring uh the same observations were
completed but this time it was with the
multi multilingual education staff and
what we observed was that there was a a
difference or a variance between the
observations that were collected in the
fall versus those that collected in the
spring. So from method methodology
perspective um there has to be kind of a
a course cor a um kind of a a correction
or normalization because which one is
ultimately like source source truth
right well would it be probably what the
multi- education department did uh but
then I also want to communicate to our
trustees that we lost funding in title 2
three and four which largely funds the
mult which contributes to the funding in
the multi education department so like
all these things have made it um
have contributed to just how we think
through how we collect the information
and report out. Um I think one three and
five are would be fine for us. I feel
like from a methodology perspective we
can present something that is
meaningful, valuable, it aligns with who
we are in constraint three um five as it
is and one um the old one that had
chronic absenteeism. I mean for a
variety of reasons that's one we're
going to attack and we're going to
attack hard, right? not only for funding
but just because it's a good thing to
make sure our kids are in our schools.
So um as far as the early learning um
you know that required walkthroughs uh
um and the um tools developed um were
kind of supplemented to other rounds of
observations that occurred. So it it
didn't necessarily it added a tool it
created more things to to kind of
evaluate and observe. Um, and so that
was kind of one of those things that was
an ad. That was something new. I I'm
trying to strike a balance here. So, if
you were to ask me kind of what feels
like a reasonable
proposal offer, uh, one, three, and five
seem fine. Like I those those are great.
Like those work well. Um, two and four
are are four was a little difficult um
this last year, but again, it was a
baseline year. Uh, and then caregiver
engagement. uh it's something we believe
in. It's something that we value. There
were some challenges with grant funding.
Uh we can overcome different elements of
it. Perhaps it ends up moving into a
pilot. I mean, there's just things that
we have to address differently because
where we are now funding wise is very
different than we were, you know, over a
year ago when we approved these
initially. So, those are just I don't
know if that's worth anything, but
hopefully that was helpful.
>> Very helpful. And I would say then um
you know constraints two and four
extremely important to me and to our
community from what we've heard. Um the
the engagement with our families is
essential that that engagement is done
in a way that is two-way that is
capacity building that is really
recognizing and valuing our families as
partners in this work and not just as
recipients of information. Um all of
those things are extremely important.
Um, and I think it's important that
those goals be represented in the
expectations from the board. However,
going back again, I don't believe
necessarily that
that this is going to move us in the
right direction without putting a huge
demand on the administration in terms of
the reporting and the development
measures. So, um, I think it's extremely
important. I don't feel think that this
is going to be the tool to get us there.
So I would just I would support removing
constraint two. Constraint four I think
is extraordinarily important because
there are many ways to improve test
scores that that result in short-term
gains that don't contribute to long-term
development of students and human beings
as we want them. And so developmentally
appropriate practices are essential for
that. And a lot of the current pressures
moving more academic things lower and
lower put tremendous pressures on not
using developmentally appropriate
practices. Um, so I think that's another
essential thing that we recognize that
our a lot of our community wants their
students to be engaged in meaningful
things that are developmentally
appropriate, not necessarily things that
are going to drill and kill them at age
four. So, um, but again, it it I don't
know that this measure is going to get
us there because if we have an effect,
if our PPFT system is aligned to
developmentally appropriate practices,
that will happen whether or not we see
these scores or not. If it's not
aligned, then seeing these scores isn't
going to help us. And so it creates a
reporting burden again that I don't
think is necessary to place on you. So I
would go with kind of the trust factor
that Dr. Foster said. I know the
superintendent we hired. I know the
staff that you've hired. I am going to
have confidence that there's a belief in
the empower importance of caregiver
engagement and there's a belief in the
importance of developing appropriate
practice to achieve the goals we have
for our kids. And I would support
removing two and four. I would not
support removing three for the reasons
of um that was revolutionary for a Texas
school board to put in some um goals and
safeguards around dual language
instruction into the goals and we've
come a long way working towards that in
this district. Um, and I think it's an
easy one again to go to shortcut easy
measures that get short-term gains for
students that ultimately from what we
know about the research will result in
um, not necessarily long-term gains. So,
I think it's really important. Um, I
think constraint three is one of them
that is most loud in our community
generally and most supported by who our
population of students are and and so I
would not support removing three. I do
support one and five.
Thank you, Trusty Fster.
>> So, um, to sort of sort of move us to a
point and also possibly ask a question,
uh, I heard the administration
basically implicitly saying retain 135,
um, dismiss two and four as sort of a
recommendation. I heard Trusty Kaufman
sort of echo that,
adding in that these things that we
would dismiss would still be important.
So I guess my question is how close is
that to the uh
u what's on what was put out as stated
and
>> I will withdraw the previous motion and
I will move to approve item 10.3 by
reducing the number of constraints to
three striking constraints two and four
>> let's just uh see if there's any
objection to that was a seconded motion
>> is there any objection to withdrawing
the motion and making a new motion.
>> Okay, seeing no objection, do we need to
make it again?
>> Yeah, just for the record.
>> Okay.
>> I approve I move to approve item 10.3 by
reducing the number of constraints to
three striking constraints two and four.
>> I second.
>> Thank you. Is there any discussion on
the motion as amended or as withdrawn
and resubmitted? Trusty Singh.
>> Okay. So, I did have um a thought around
um constraint one um underserved
students and the special ed evaluations
and I am concerned I am thinking about
like our our time constraints on as
we're up here and I know that we are
required to talk about do sped
monitoring.
Could we
get TEA to not make this time count
against us when we're talking about sped
evaluations
>> or could we include that in our sped
updates?
>> So, I mean I Josh certainly come up here
and correct me when I say something
incorrect. Um, my understanding is that
as long as the TA read order is in
effect, um, anything tied to the order
would count. But I think given our
objective of getting out of the order, I
don't know because we don't know when
that'll be. At some point midy year, did
all of a sudden the time not count? Um,
that would be something I I would want
to at least consider. Um, I just don't
know. We are actively trying to get past
that.
>> Yes. And the goals uh monitoring goals
will count towards student outcomes time
>> and monitoring constraints will count
towards high leverage adult focus time.
>> No. No,
>> no,
>> it counts again.
>> It's regular adult focus time.
>> Regular adult focus.
>> So, it's the other 50%.
>> Um,
>> Ashley, yeah, unless you're hearing
something different than Arthy and I
heard,
>> I move to call the question.
>> Um,
>> okay.
>> In interest of time,
>> okay, there's a motion to call the
question. Do we want to continue
speaking? What do we um What's our Is
there a second? What does that mean? To
move to call. I don't think I don't
think it requires a second.
>> Doesn't require a second.
>> So, you just have to
>> Yeah.
>> Wait. So,
>> call the question
>> to stop discussion in the interest of
time.
>> And we can vote to stop discussion or
continue discussing.
>> Wait. So,
>> I would like to continue discussing
because I like because that would impact
my vote.
>> Um,
>> so yeah. Okay. So let's vote on the
motion to call the question. All in
favor of calling the question, raise
your right hand.
Any opposed?
Okay. So we will continue discussion.
Thank you. Okay. Trusty Singh, do you
have?
>> Yeah. So I guess what would be really
helpful is if we I I because I am really
concerned that the things we talk about
under constraint one
because it's a constraint would count
against us in terms of the like it would
count as adult focused minutes. Um
that's TEA's term not mine. Um I'm gonna
sorry to interrupt. Um
>> do you have clarification
>> Ashley? Uh I believe yes says that Josh
is correct and it is high leverage adult
focused time
are the constraints.
>> So is that
>> so the constraints are high leverage
adult focused time
>> or R are
>> I believe are I I will await a text
zoom
>> in.
>> Thank you.
>> Can can I ask a different clarifying
question?
>> Wait hold on. Yeah. But okay. So she is
she gonna come on Zoom or
>> I don't think we have a Zoom set up but
what I what we're hearing is that Josh
is correct. Thank you.
>> So so the constraints would count
towards um high leverage adult focus
time which is not student outcomes but
it will count towards the 50% under the
order.
>> Thank you.
>> The 50% of student outcome time
>> in that umbrella. Yes. Not
>> not it is not technically student
outcomes but it will count towards the
50% required under the agreed order.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Okay. So that's the opposite of a text I
received. I mean an email from Ashley.
So I'm a little
>> but Ashley's confirming it right now. So
I believe
>> so it will not
>> video. It's on video.
>> It's on video. So I'm just confirming
that we have heard from Ashley,
>> our LSG coach. And I love you, Ashley,
but I gotta just really confirm this
that constraints discussions are not
going to count against us. They will
count as part of the 50% student
outcomes minutes and it won't be neutral
and it won't be adult minute time. It'll
be part of the student outcomes time.
>> Yes, ma'am. Part of student outcomes
time, but it is in that
>> it's not called student outcomes. a high
leverage adult, but it counts as in that
bucket that we're supposed to do 50%.
>> That we have to hit at least the 50%
threshold.
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Josh. Sorry.
>> Thank you, Josh. And thank you, Ashley.
Um, Trusty Singh, any further comments?
Nope. Okay. Anyone else? Any comments?
Okay. I have a couple of brief comments.
Um, I hear what the administration's
saying. about um and and I'm very
supportive of constraint one um because
even after we're out past our agreed
order, I think continuing to monitor
that to make sure we don't um revert
back is valuable. Um I also want to note
that constraint progress measure one is
really just restating what we owe under
law. So it's nothing above and beyond.
It is just what we owe. Constraint two
um exclusionary discipline. I see a lot
of reason to monitor that. We know that
has been a significant issue. The data
in the chart in front of us show us that
um constraint to caregiver engagement.
Um
I understand this is an imperfect
measure. It's also something every
campus needs to make a campus
improvement plan. So I don't see this as
being um I hear what the administration
is saying, but I also think this doesn't
have to be an expensive thing. It
doesn't have to be a complicated thing.
Although I am hearing what the
administration says and I do think right
now we're hearing from our community
that they don't feel engaged
um right this very moment about the
targeted improvement plans um or the
turnaround plans and I think that is
notable to me. Um, I came to the board
as someone deeply involved in family
engagement districtwide on the board of
the Austin Council P of PTAs for many
years and um have seen that there are
campuses that engage authentically and
that treat families as partners and
sometimes there are campuses that don't
and um I I think that's deeply baked in
and I know there's there's great um
intention for this and great goodwill
and I think we've seen that it doesn't
happen. Um, I think even an imperfect
measure is sending a message to our
community and to the administration that
this matters to us. And I do think any
document like this is not um best
intended to respond to the very moment
we're in, but is intended to be
something durable, more durable than
this moment. Um, I hope our
superintendent doesn't change. We gave
you a five-year contract. Things change.
Um, and I think responding because we
have trust in pulling something off. Um
that's one of the very few ways right
now that we have a way to tell our
community we care more about more than
standardized test scores. Um in a moment
when standardized test scores have
greater and greater weight has meaning
to me. um dual language. I appreciate
keeping it and I do really support um
removing the seal of biiteracy from our
goals and and hope that's responsive to
what the administration has asked
because I do think this is a more
meaningful measure. I think it revealed
some things to us um through data that
our community had been telling us for a
long time. Um, and I agree with Trusty
Kaufman that that to really me measure
the fidelity matters. And I think this
um the lack of fidelity is part of what
we're seeing in the unacceptable ratings
at some of our campuses. I think this is
intimately tied to the work we're doing
right now and um is a deep value in our
community. Um
early learning again um we're telling
our community who we are and what we
believe. Um, we're talking about our
district to families who get to choose
us or choose anything else under the
sun. You know, people now get to choose
charters. They're going to have next
year vouchers for private school, for
homeschool. Um, we are in this moment in
part because people are choosing other
things. And again, I think you can't
hijack human development. Um, humans
need what they need and leaning into
that as a community matters as well. And
again, it's not a perfect measure, but I
think it is a meaningful goal um and
accountability. I I really appreciate
everyone's work to make sure we have put
that there. But again, that is measuring
um really are we complying with what we
have to do under the law. So, I don't
see that as a a lofty goal. I think it
is just restating and watching um what
we owe and and one thing that we are
working hard to meet under the new
accountability system. um didn't meet
perfectly before but have a bigger hill
decline now. Um, and I do want to go
back to our budget conversation when we
were talking about our goals and our
constraints and the administration
brought those really great charts for
every proposed cut or investment that
showed the whole circle, half circle,
empty circle about the impact that each
item that was we were looking at line by
line in the budget of investments and
reductions would have on the things on
our scorecard. Um, we are told that this
isn't just, you know, a document that we
talk about, but it's a document that
drives the work. It's a document that
drives our budgets. It's a document that
drives other things. And removing it is
not uh removing it because we trust the
administration isn't without impact. Um,
and trusting it versus seeing it and
showing it to our community are two
different things. Um, so that is where I
am on this and I understand it's work,
but um, it takes a lot of work to show
our community what we're doing and
talking about it for me in a meeting um,
with the superintendent or getting it in
a board update is not the same as
telling our community that these things
our community has told us are their
values are are that we have heard them
and we are paying attention to them. Um,
so that is my comment. Any other
comments before we vote?
Okay. So, here's our motion. Um, having
a motion by trustee Whitley Chu, Vice
President Whitley Chu, and a second by
Trustee Foster to approve 10.3 by
reducing our constraints to three, and
striking constraints uh constraint two,
which is caregiver engagement, and
striking constraint four, which is early
learning. That means the ones that
remain will be number one about
underserved students, number three about
dual language, and number five about
accountability.
And striking the other two. Um, all in
favor, please raise your right hand.
Any opposed?
Sorry. All in favor, please raise your
right hand.
Any opposed? And the motion passes. Um,
six in favor to oppose. Thank you.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you very much. Okay.
That was a long discussion and Ashley,
thank you for your guidance. Um, and
lawyers, thank you for your guidance.
>> I'd like to I'd like to call I don't
know what the terminology is, but I want
to make sure we got the vote correct
because I thought I saw Kaufman sing
Hunter opposing.
>> Oh, Hunter, were you opposing or No,
Hunter opposed the first time and we
voted. Yeah, we Yes, you it was Kaufman
and Boswell opposing.
>> Okay. My my apologies. Thank you for
clarifying.
>> You voted in favor.
>> It was It was to keep trains three and
>> 1 three and five.
>> Yes.
>> Absolutely.
>> Sorry, muddy in the water.
>> Thank you. No, I that's important to
have the record.
>> No, I don't think you needed to do it
again, but I do think before you move
on, it would be good to make a motion
just to be clear that we're approving an
actual score.
>> I move to adopt a new scorecard with the
goals and constraints approved by the
board in the two previous votes.
>> Second.
>> Second. Thank you. Uh having a motion by
Vice President Willie Chu to approve the
scorecard as amended by the two previous
votes and a second by trustee Kintana.
Uh is there any discussion?
We've discussed a lot. Uh all in favor,
please raise your right hand.
Any opposed?
And the motion passes by all those on
the dis. Um thank you very much. Um,
okay. We are going to move on um to our
next pulled item and and there is a
cascade um that we've been referring to
as our order of operations to get all of
these handled in one meeting as um we
need to. So, um Josh, updates to the
board monitoring calendar. Are you ready
to do that or do we need to do that
after our exact session?
>> Okay. So, we're going to hold that one
until after our executive session. So
there is an opportunity um to address
that. Um approval of amendments to the
board guard rails is our next
um I move to approve agenda item 10.5 by
reducing the number of guardrails to one
um striking guardrails one and three.
Okay. Uh is there a second?
Second. Okay. Having a motion by Vice
President Willie Chu to uh approve the
Austin ISD board guard rails by striking
one and three and approving two. Um a
second by Trustee Hunter. Um is there
any discussion? Trusty Coffin. I think
we have a lot of expectations that we
set for the superintendent and
administration and I think it's
reasonable that we set expectations for
ourselves through the same process. Um
as we go into the
um upcoming votes um to discuss the
consolidation plan. Um, I think, you
know, I made a commitment to a school
board or to a PTA the other night that
this board, I do not believe, will make
any decisions that involve horse trading
and behind the scene, political deals or
deals that would secure someone's, you
know, something for someone's district
at the expense of another part of town
or something that would secure someone a
personal gain at the expense of the, you
know, the district as a whole. And so,
um, in making that commitment to that
community, I can't make that commitment.
I can only make that commitment on my
own, what I commit to. Um, but I think
it's important to include guardrail 3 so
that we're making that commitment as a
board.
>> Thank you. Uh, additional questions or
comments?
>> Uh, trusty Foster. And then
>> just just seeking clarification because
again I I misread or I'm misreading the
document. I see a one guardrail one,
guardrail 2, guardrail 3. I thought the
red cutout and the blue cutout was for
guardrail 2.
>> Correct.
>> The blue is the new language of
guardrail 2. We're reapproving these
because guardrail 2 did not meet the
requirements of lonear governance. It
had too many items and it had a double
negative and we had to rewrite it to
make it compliant so we could check it
on our board self-evaluation. So the
guard rail one is retained, two is
retained, three is retained.
>> The proposal is to have only the
language in the blue. The the proposal
is for our only guardrail to be the
board will not fail to support each
other by working collaboratively as we
govern and oversee the management of
Austin ISD. That's the motion but not
what's in our packet was the initial
proposal that was on the agenda, which
was to include guardrail one, an amended
guard rail 2, and a guardrail 3. The pro
the motion made by Vice President Willy
Chu is to include only guardrail 2 and
to delete guardrails one and three.
>> Okay. So I kind of shouldn't be looking
at this for Okay, now I'm understanding
a little bit better. There is a simple
oneline guardrail.
I
love being in compliance with you know
all things state. Um I am with the
notion that we need to be held to high
standards and accounts and it always
bothers me if like I got one line I just
be good and then everybody else has this
well elaborated you know so there's
something that gives me an element of
discomfort
but I also am beyond
this linguistic mishmash of whether it's
scorecards guard rails or anything it is
only a portion of the work I see myself
and I see us accountable to a whole lot
more than one line.
I'm willing to approve one line, go with
one line because that's what's
efficacious right now,
but I hold myself to a higher standard
than just the one line.
Maybe worth stay stating. Maybe not.
>> Thank you, Trusty. Our state,
>> just a clarifying question, are there
LSG issues with the other two
guardrails?
>> There are not. We had to change the
language on number two to make it fit
the rules. There are no issues with one
and three and we adopted one the old two
and three in the past. Um our coach
Ashley Paw has been working with TEA's
um governance director, director of
governance to check all of our
deliverables. Um they they flagged we're
really cleaning up issues they found
with our deliverables
um to ensure that we have done it all so
we can you know kind of
so they can certify that we have met our
obligations under the tea agreed order
in service of the work that we've been
doing for the past two years. Does that
clarify?
>> Yeah, I just want to make sure. So then,
you know, for for my point, I'm not
hearing any um rationale yet for
removing the other two guard rails if
they're not um a foul of of any LSG
rationale. And so I would just offer
that if if I'm putting three goals for
the administration and three constraints
for the administration, I I would not
feel good having less constraint or
obligation than the than the district
does.
>> I move to withdraw the motion.
>> Withdraw the motion.
>> Okay. Any objections?
>> Okay. Um do we have a new motion?
>> Yes.
>> I move to approve agenda item 10.5.
second.
>> Okay. Uh is there any discussion?
>> So now I mean for clarity for folks who
aren't
reading along seven documents deep into
this stuff, um guardrail one has to do
with the notion that we will not exclude
community voices, that we will be
listeners. Um, guardrail two is that we
are not going to fail to support each
other as trustees in working
collaboratively. Uh, guardrail three is
that we are not going to seek favor to a
district or, you know, a subdist at the
expense of the whole and we're not going
to, I guess, benefit individually. So
that speaks to community, that speaks to
how we treat each other, that speaks to,
you know, just basic ethics. I like it.
Thank you. Any further discussion?
Okay, perfect. Having a motion by Vice
President Willie Chu and a second by
Trusty Kaufman to approve item 10.5. All
in favor, please raise your hand. And
the motion passes by all those on the
dice. Thank you for the discussion and
the vote. Um, okay. Next, um, 10.6.
Um, and I believe this is another one
that we're going to vote on after our
exact session. So, there's time to bring
it into compliance because that is part
of that as well. Okay. So, um I believe
we are moving on now. This is um we are
moving on now to section 16 items for
separate vote. Um attorneys, am I
missing anything?
>> Um I don't think so. Okay, very good.
Uh, glad to have a second set of eyes.
Okay, so we're moving the items of se uh
for a separate vote. Vice President
Willie Chu, do we have an uh motion to
approve item 14.1?
>> Yes.
I move that the property tax rate be
adopted at a tax rate of
u n of 92 cents and 5200s of a cent per
$100 of assessed valuation which is
effectively a decrease to the total tax
rate. The adopted tax rate of 92 cents
and 5200s of a cent represents a
decrease of 2 cents and 5300s of a cent
from last year's total tax rate. The
adopted tax rate of.9252
will fund the 2025 2026 budget and
reflects
an 80 cents and 2200s of a cent
maintenance and operations tax rate
of.123
interest and syncing tax rate. The
interest and syncing tax rate will be
used for the purpose of providing a
syncing fund to be used to pay principal
and interest on bonds issued or assumed
by the district.
Uh do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Um is there any discussion?
And to clarify with our council, we have
two separate motions and two separate
actions in this agenda item.
>> Correct.
>> Yes. Okay. And I don't need to reread
the motion. Correct. Or do I
>> correct? Uh you can if you want to, but
you don't have to.
>> Oh, no. I don't want to. Thank you.
Okay. Um having a motion by trustee
Whitley Chu um about the tax rate.
Motion number one for this item and a
second by trustee Kintana. All in favor,
please raise your right hand.
>> Okay. Motion passes by all those on the
dis. Uh Vice President Whitley Chu, do I
have a motion on the second portion of
this? I move that all properties defined
by the city of Austin as historical
landmark properties be granted a partial
tax exemption pursuant to that certain
ordinance adopted by the Austin ISD
Board of Trustees on April 9th, 1979 and
as amended on September 12th, 1994,
August 29th, 2005, and June 18th, 2012.
>> Okay. Do we have a second?
>> What was that item number? It's under
16.1. There are two motions under item
16.1. We've we've taken action on the
first motion. This is the second motion.
>> Second.
>> Okay. Um is there any discussion on this
item?
>> Okay. Having um
>> yes by trustee Kintana.
>> Uh yeah, just a sort of point of
clarification when we talk about the
historic landmark properties. Are these
generally um individual residences? Are
these buildings downtown? Um what
properties are we talking about? How
many?
>> Um so uh they are generally um uh
residential homes uh historic in nature.
Um I can't speak to the quant the count.
I'm sure we could pull that from the uh
the tax from the um
>> I don't want to misspeost. I I would
have to go back. Um I could probably get
that to you relatively quickly, but I
don't have it. Um I don't believe it's
dozens. Um, but I also don't believe
it's very very very very large number.
I'll have to hit
>> Yeah, but it's it's mostly single family
historic homes.
Thank you.
>> Do you know the number?
>> Sorry, Trusty Foster. I wasn't
>> No, that's my bad.
>> I would estimate similar between dozens
and more than dozens fewer than
thousands. Yeah.
>> And correct. And what these are in in
effect are tax breaks uh predominantly
to predominantly to residences that have
been able to secure a historic
designation for their home.
>> Uh yes, that's correct. Um the
designation I I'm I know there's city of
Austin designation. I'm not sure if
there's a state one as well. I know they
I'm not sure what designation they rely
on. Um but we rely on that um to kind of
allow for the exemption
>> um
>> 470
>> 47
>> so more than dozens less than a
thousand. So trustee President Basel and
I were both in the range.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Any further discussion?
Right. Having a motion by Vice President
Willie Chu and a second by Trustee
Kintana to approve motion number two
under item 16.1. All in favor, please
raise your right hand.
Any opposed? And the motion passes 7 to
one with Trusty Foster voting in
opposition. Um,
oh, I don't want to take a lot of time,
but I do want to answer the third and
fourth graders that ask, "When am I ever
going to use place value?" This evening.
There you go. Math teacher.
It's a good thing. Okay. Thank you all.
Okay. Um, item 16.2 has been removed.
Um, item 16.3, we'll move on to um,
yeah, item 16.2 was pulled by the
administration, so we'll move to 16.3.
I move to approve agenda item 16.3
approval of 2026 2027 budget development
calendar.
>> Do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Any discussion?
>> Yes.
>> Did we say this was going to get amended
or this is cemented?
>> Did we say the budget calendar was going
to be amended?
>> Yes.
>> I think just your your motion was to
approve it as it is. It it is amended
>> agenda
>> always okay already. Okay.
>> Okay. From last time
>> I just wanted to ask if it met the
change
>> poss. Yeah. So um
are we at the point where we can have
discussion?
>> We yes we are discussing this.
>> So um thank you. I put a lot of stuff
there. Um but ju just yeah so I I really
look forward to getting doing the board
approval of the three-year plan to ret
restore our fund balance to 20% in
December. That's super important and
something that we've been talking about
out in the community a lot as part of
the justification for doing the school
consolidation. So this is an opportunity
I think for us to to really um see that.
Um and also the approving the
consultation agreement a month before
the actual full budget vote um is really
helpful I think because that is the
majority of our budget and it it does
allow us to um make sure we're all on
the same page with that. I did want to
ask about the um line row 24. Um, thank
you for in sort of expanding what's what
we're going to be impro approving in
November. Um, it says here the board
approval of the campus consolidation
package, boundary changes, transition
plans, reallocating of bond funds. Um,
and then it kind of stopped there last
week when we saw this and you added um
it would also include the academic
framework development process and
academic foundation. Um, I was hoping to
see the term baseline academic program
and so I I because that is just
something that came directly out of the
long range plan and I wanted to just
make that really obvious. Um, so I'm
wondering if we if the administration
would um, and I'm not really making a
motion, but I just want to have more
discussion. Would we be open to adding
the phrase including a baseline academic
plan
and the associated budget? I don't know
if that would be too much of a lift
between now and November, the budget
piece of it, or if that could just be
part rolled into the December plan.
>> Yeah. So um
so the two things I think that um this
is where I think to find words and
searching for words to describe
something that hasn't been yet presented
uh is challenging. So I have no problem
uh amending uh baseline academic
program. I just want to make sure it's
clear kind of we all understand what
that document is going to look like and
what it's not going to look like. Um and
so um if you're amunable to that then I
would remove academic foundation because
I think many of the things that we're
talking about are in both. Uh we were
just struggling for kind of the precise
language to use to encapsulate
everything we wanted to encapsulate but
also acknowledge there was going to be
more work to come which is why
foundation was the word that I chose to
use Matias uh no one else. Um and so uh
yeah I'm I'm fine with that. I think
what we can we would um offer is maybe
um uh in the next meeting a framework
for what that document is going to look
like. So there's an understanding in
November that it's not going to be the
result of an 18-month effort. It's
really
>> it's like a draft.
>> It's it's a it's a correct.
>> Yeah. Um, as far as the budget uh
component of it, I I do want to kind of
communicate, and I've said this before,
that this is one of mult many many steps
>> uh in an effort to get our organization
where it needs to be. Um, and so the
things that we talk about won't be fully
supported in our budget um by way of
these consolidations or cuts, there are
many things that will have to happen to
get us where we need to be. So to say
that there's a necessarily a value
exchange immediately at this point
before the votes and before the actions
take place, I wouldn't necessarily be
comfortable getting to that level.
>> Understood. So could are you
anticipating in line in row 24 as part
of the consolidation package some
financial data that just says like okay
because we're we're getting these
questions a lot. So, so yes, the
financial modeling to the to communicate
the expected um loss reduction in cost
associated with that
>> um with with the um changes. Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Um and as I we're operating at a
deficit, so we have to make the deficit
up to correct. And so that that's where
I get really anxious about
>> just immediately communicating that if
we do this and all of a sudden this new
thing will occur.
>> Correct.
>> You know, we we made investments in
compensation in 23, 24, 20. I mean,
we've done a lot and I I I just don't
want that to be missed.
>> No, no, I get it. I get it. Like, I I'm
with you on that. So, I I would like if
we could if and this would be I would
like to hear from other trustees, but
like I would love to see the phrase
baseline academic plan or program,
whatever we use in the LRP. Um that same
phraseology phrasing would be really
good. And then um something about the
financial modeling because I don't see I
mean obviously this is in the budget
document but we don't actually mention
the financial models um that come from
the consolidation consolidation. So I
think it would be helpful to include
that as part of the consolidation.
>> Yeah we were I was intending to do that.
I just was doing as part of the
consolidation timeline and milestones
not the budget. Um, but I'm hap we're
going to do it, so I'm happy to include
it wherever you like.
>> Thank you. I I know I I've I've told
people that like people are like, "How
much should we save in 2019?" I'm like,
"I don't really know." But I do know
that they're going to tell us what what
they anticipated savings and revenues
would be from the consolidations going
forward. And if that's not true, then I
need to change what I'm saying. But if
it is true, then let's just put it in
there. Um that would
>> I don't know how others kind of feel
about that but that's just
>> I mean I have
>> okay
>> I mean I
>> so then I
>> I guess one question um as far as
timeline goes I mean we're I mean it's
I'm happy to to modify and then come
back after exact session and vote on it.
I mean because we could upload
>> three updates.
>> Well, just the Well, we just modify that
line,
>> right? There are three three
>> one remove two two words, add three
words and then add a comma and then two
more words.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh and so we do that and then upload a
second version to the then we can do
that. That would be that I think it
would meet the motion, meet the comment,
and then
>> and you might want to update line 49 as
well because it also refers to the
academic foundation council. Are
>> we tableabling it and coming back?
>> I would uh Yeah, you can table it.
>> I really appreciate that. Sorry y'all.
>> Okay, we'll table we'll come back. We
have several votes later. And I would
just love to point out on uh line four
uh for the truth and taxation online
publication that we need. Um we have
truth and a capital N, which I think
it's truth in taxation. That makes it
sound a whole lot more casual and fun
than it really is. Um so I would love to
just fix that before we vote. Okay.
Anything any further discussion?
Okay. Um any objection to tableabling
this motion? Uh so the administration
can make some changes as discussed.
Okay. Perfect. Um thank you. And
um
we have everything else uh that we need
to do will happen either um after our
close session. Uh we have some transfer
appeals to come back. So yeah, I think
um now I need to find my page.
Pardon me.
Okay. We will now recess the open
meeting at 8:43 p.m. 8:44 p.m. and move
to executive session pursuant to Texas
Government Code sections 551.074. 074
551.072
551.073
551.087
551.076
551.0821
and 551.071.
When we are finished with the executive
session, we will briefly return to the
open session to take action on the
transfer appeals agenda items um 10
hold on
10.4 10.6 six and now also
16.3.
Uh and we will also um formally adjourn
the meeting at that point. The actions
in the adjournment will be recorded and
included in all replays of tonight's
meeting. Thank you for joining us and
have a good night.
Uh we will now reconvene the open
meeting at 10:50 p.m. and uh move on to
decision on student transfer appeals.
Um, first up is um
18.1. The following board members are
present.
Oh no, sorry.
Um, we are in open session now. So, um,
we will now consider agenda item 18.1,
the transfer appeal on behalf of NG. Do
I have a motion on that agenda item?
Yes.
>> I move to affirm the decision of the
superintendent and deni deny the relief
requested.
>> Do I have a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Um is there any discussion?
>> Right.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. I want to acknowledge again that in
the response to this um transfer appeal,
there was evidence of direct connection
with attempting to solve the challenges
of the family and address their
concerns. And I appreciate that effort
by the the administration to address the
concerns of the family.
>> Thank you. Uh any further discussion?
>> All right. Having a motion by trustee
Whitley Chu and a second by Trustee
Kintana. All in favor, please raise your
right hand. And the motion passes by all
on the dis. And we're going to move on
to 18.2
at the transfer appeal of QT.
Do I have a motion on agenda item 18.2,
the transfer appeal on behalf of QT?
>> I move to affirm the decision of the
superintendent and deny the relief
requested.
>> Thank you. Do I have a second?
>> Second,
Trusty Hunter.
Uh, thank you for a second. Is there any
discussion?
All right. Thank you. Um, I'll just add
that there was evidence of the same in
this one and that is appreciated. Thank
you to staff um for connecting
thoughtfully with families. Um, okay.
Having a motion by Vice President Willy
Chu, a second by Trustee Hunter um on
agenda item 18.2. All in favor, please
raise your right hand. And the motion
passes by all those on the dis. Um we
will now move on to items for separate
vote um that we discussed during our
general meeting. Vice President Willie
Chu, do we have a motion to approve item
10.4?
Well, but we also have the board the two
board things.
>> I move to approve item 10.4, approval of
updates to the board monitoring
calendar.
>> Yeah, they changed it in exec. So, you
can just approve it as second while we
were in exec.
>> Okay. Um Okay. So, we have a motion and
a second on item 10.4. Is there any
discussion on this item?
All right. Having a motion by Vice
President Willie Chu and a second by
trustee Kintana to approve item 10.4. Uh
all those in favor please raise your
right hand. And the motion passes by all
those on the dis. Okay. Vice President
Willie Chu. Do we have a motion to
approve item 10.6?
>> Yes. I move to approve agenda item 10.6.
Approval of amendments to the board
handbook which includes updates to the
scorecard with the approval of 10.3 and
updates to the board guard rails with
the approval of 10.5.
And I believe it also needs to approve
the uh include the monitoring calendar
>> as approved. Calendar is not in it.
Okay, perfect. Thank you. Okay. Uh is
there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh is there any discussion on
this item?
>> All right. Having a motion by Vice
President Whitley Chu and a second by
Trustee Kaufman to approve item 10.6.
All those in favor, please raise your
right hand.
And the motion passes by all those on
the dis. Um final item is um agenda item
16.3.
Trust uh Vice President Willy Chu, do we
have a motion on 16.3
and it's not on the script?
>> Okay. Yes. I move to approve agenda item
16.3.
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Uh is there any discussion?
Okay, having a motion by Vice President
Willy Chu and a second by trustee Singh
to approve item 16.3. All those in
favor, please raise your right hand. And
the motion passes by all those on the
dis. Vice President Whitley Chu, do I
have a motion to adjourn the meeting?
>> I move to adjourn the meeting.
>> And the meeting is adjourned at 10:55
p.m. Thank you all so much.